I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on the office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Lady, we have a great day today.
We have another revisited deep dive episode of Office Ladies.
我是詹娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极办公室爱好者播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，更深入地探索办公室的世界。我们是Office Ladies 6.0。各位女士，我们今天过得真棒。我们有另一个Office Ladies重温深度剖析单集。
Yes, today we are going to go back over the.
second half of season three. We're going to get to your questions, your comments about all the things
we missed. We're doing everything from back from vacation to the job. Yeah, we are. And I want you to know,
I'm holding what looks like a small phone book in my hand because we went through so many questions
and comments and Jen and I both jotted a ton down and we're excited to talk to you guys today. Yeah,
it's like 19, 20 pages, I think. It is. It is. But first, we have some excited.
news, we are going to start this off with a deep dive with our awesome cinematographer and director
Randall Einhorn. Randall was the cinematographer for 64 episodes, and he directed the
是的，今天我们要回顾第三季的后半部分。我们将解答你们的问题、你们对我们错过的所有事情的评论。我们从度假归来到求职，无所不包。是的，确实如此。我想让你们知道，我手里拿着一个看起来像小型电话簿的东西，因为我们收到了太多的问题和评论，詹娜和我两人的记事本上都写满了东西，我们很高兴今天能和大家聊聊。是的，大概有19、20页，我想。是的。确实如此。但首先，我们有一些令人兴奋的消息，我们将以与我们出色的摄影指导兼导演兰德尔·艾恩霍恩的深度访谈来拉开序幕。兰德尔曾担任64集的摄影指导，他还执导了
accountant's webisodes, as well as 15 episodes of The Office. This man knows this show inside and out.
We are so excited to talk to him. Guys, Randall was one of our original visionaries for the show.
He really helped shape the world, the mockumentary style. He is,
also been amazing. I've been reaching out to him. You've been reaching out to him, Angela. You might
remember he gave us all of the amazing details about Michael's car going into the lake. So we are really
excited to get this deep dive interview with him for the pod. So you guys, when we all got on
the Zoom with Randall, we were so excited to see each other. It was the first time the three of us.
I mean, Jenna, I don't even know the last time the three of us were together. So we got super
会计师网络短片，以及15集《办公室》。这个人对这部剧了如指掌。我们非常高兴能与他交谈。伙计们，兰德尔是这部剧最初的远见卓识者之一。他真正帮助塑造了这个世界，即伪纪录片风格。他也一直非常出色。我一直在联系他。你一直在联系他，安吉拉。你可能还记得，他向我们提供了迈克尔的车冲进湖里的所有惊人细节。所以我们真的很高兴能为播客对进行这番深度采访。所以你们知道，当我们所有人在Zoom上与兰德尔连线时，我们看到彼此都非常兴奋。这是我们三个人第一次。我是说，詹娜，我甚至不知道我们三个人最后一次聚在一起是什么时候。所以我们变得超级
excited. We did all of our hellos and forgot to hit record.
Yes. Sam was like, guys, are you recording? And I was like, oh, crap. Yeah. So when you hear this interview, we're going to jump right in. Because we talked for 20 minutes without hitting record. Yeah. Oh, Sam. Sam, Sam, Sam,
every week, you're like, Ann, should you hit record? Every week. Sam, can you play that interview?
Randall, we always start by asking people basically the same question, which is how did you come to be on the office?
I was doing a reality TV show, kind of an extreme sports thing where I had to ski with Sean White and some other legendary skier.
And I had to keep up with these guys skiing and film these extreme skiers in Jackson Hole.
It was kind of an extreme sports thing for Ben Sowerman.
And Ben at that time apparently decided that's the guy.
兴奋。我们互相问候了一番，却忘了按下录音键。是的。山姆当时说，伙计们，你们在录音吗？然后我说，哦，糟了。是的。所以当你听到这段采访时，我们会直接切入正题。因为我们聊了20分钟却没按录音键。是的。哦，山姆。山姆，山姆，山姆，每星期你都会说，安，你按录音键了吗？每个星期。山姆，你能播放那段采访吗？兰德尔，我们总是以向人们提出基本相同的问题开始，那就是你是怎么来到《办公室》的？我当时正在拍一个真人秀电视节目，有点像极限运动节目，我必须和肖恩·怀特以及其他一些传奇滑雪者一起滑雪。我必须跟上这些滑雪者的步伐，在杰克逊霍尔拍摄这些极限滑雪者。对本·索尔曼来说，这有点像极限运动节目。本当时显然决定，就是这个人了。
Wait, when he decided this, were you flying down a mountain holding a camera?
Yeah.
I would say that's the guy too.
I would say that's the guy for anything.
But it is a curious jump to go from guy filming on skis to filming a quiet contained office cubicle.
Yes.
I went from outdoor adventure guy to the office guy.
Ben convinced Greg that that's the guy.
等等，当他做出这个决定时，你是不是正拿着摄像机冲下山坡？是的。我想我也会觉得那是那个人。我会认为那是任何事情的最佳人选。但从一个在滑雪板上拍摄的家伙，转变为拍摄一个安静、封闭的办公室隔间，这是一个奇怪的跳跃。是的。我从户外冒险家变成了办公室小哥。本说服了格雷格，这就是那个人。
I remember Greg and I met at a Starbucks.
And Greg said, you just meet me at the Starbucks on Santa Monica.
I was new to Los Angeles.
and I went to one of the 50s Starbucks in Los Angeles.
And I finally got in touch with Greg.
And I showed up like an hour late.
And Greg is still sitting there just waiting for me.
And we had a fantastic meeting.
我记得格雷格和我在一家星巴克见面了。格雷格说，你在圣莫尼卡的星巴克见我吧。我刚到洛杉矶，我去了洛杉矶50家星巴克中的一家。我终于联系上了格雷格。我大概迟到了一个小时。而格雷格依然坐在那里等着我。我们有了一次非常棒的会面。
And it was wonderful.
And that's where Greg and I really hit it off.
Did you bring Matt Sown into the picture?
He was the B camera operator.
Yes.
Had you worked together before?
Yeah, you guys knew each other, right?
Matt and I knew each other from the outdoor adventure world and also from Survivor and Eco Challenge.
而且非常美好。也就是在那里，格雷格和我真正一见如故。你把马特·索恩带进来了吗？他是B机摄影师。是的。你们以前合作过吗？是的，你们互相认识，对吧？我和马特在户外冒险界就认识，也在《幸存者》和《生态挑战》中认识。
And we filmed scenes together.
And when you're filming a scene together in kind of this Verite style, you know, documentary style, you really ascertain really quickly,
who's looking out for you and who's doing the compliment of what you're doing.
And that Verite dance, Matt and I did really, really well.
I remember just a couple times that we've shot together and he's like, oh, he gets it.
doing and I get what he's doing. And we can look at each other out of, you know, out of the eye
that's not behind the camera and, and communicate. And I just felt Matt was the best person for me
to do that dance with. Randall, were you so bored to be inside of this cubicle warehouse office
我们一起拍摄过场景。当你在这种真实主义风格、你知道的纪录片风格中一起拍摄场景时，你很快就能确定，谁在照顾你，谁在做你所做事情的补充。这种真实主义舞蹈，我和马特配合得非常好。我记得有几次我们一起拍摄，他说，哦，他懂他在做什么，我也懂他在做什么。我们可以透过镜头后面的那只眼睛（你知道的）互相看着对方，并进行交流。我觉得马特是我跳那支舞的最佳人选。兰德尔，在经历了你们拍摄过的一切之后，待在这个装有荧光灯的隔间仓库办公室空间里，你觉得无聊吗？
space with these fluorescent lights after all you guys had shot? No, I mean, we had shot. We had
always shot things that we just reacted to. That's what Cinema Very
I tell you is you're just reacting. You're just gleaning what's happening around you. And it was really cool to kind of reverse engineer that and actually have to make it look like you were just getting it. I never really worked in narrative stuff before. I'd always done, you know, reality and documentaries. And it was really cool to make scripted stuff look like a documentary because it took another layer of finesse. You know, normally you're just sitting there and you're filming what happens and you're just sitting there on a trot. Had we had we been.
sitting there on dollies or on a tripod and I'm just know what everybody's going to say and I'm just
doing pans. Yeah, I would have been born. But to be able to react and, you know, and play a character.
You were. You were a character. You were. Thank you. Yeah. You know what, though? I did always think of
you guys. I mean, Jenna and I have talked about this because we knew like some of the adventures you and Matt
had had. You had shared with us on set. We always sort of.
不，我是说，我们拍过。我们总是拍摄那些我们只是做出反应的东西。这就是所谓的“真实电影”，你只是在做出反应。你只是在收集周围发生的事情。以某种方式逆向工程，实际上必须让它看起来像是你刚刚得到的，这真的很酷。我以前从未真正从事过叙事类的内容。我总是做（你知道的）真人秀和纪录片。把带剧本的东西拍得像纪录片一样真的很酷，因为这需要另一层技巧。通常情况下，你只是坐在那里，拍摄发生的事件，你只是坐在三脚架上。如果我们一直坐在摇臂或三脚架上，而我确切知道每个人要说什么，我只是在平移。是的，我会觉得无聊。但能够做出反应，（你知道的）并扮演一个角色。你就是。你就是一个角色。你就是。谢谢。是的。你知道吗？不过，我确实总是想到你们。我是说，詹娜和我讨论过这个，因为我们知道你和马特有过的一些冒险经历。你在片场和我们分享过。每当我们在片场遇到诸如点燃的蜡烛这样的情况时，我们总是会心一笑。而我们的副导演凯莉·坎特利就会说：“安全会议，我们要点燃一支蜡烛。”就像詹娜和我深知你曾经把摄像机绑在自己身上，去过像婆罗洲河流里的一些小船那样的地方，对于兰德尔来说就是：好的，点燃蜡烛。明白了。是的。是的。关于蜡烛的安全会议相当……它们显然是一回事。直到今天这依然让我印象深刻。但我认为这一切都是以安全的名义进行的，因为安全永不放假。所以没错。是的。
chuckled when we would have a situation like a lit candle on stage. And Kelly Cantley,
our AD, would be like, safety meeting, we're going to light a candle. And like Jenna and I knowing
that you had a camera strapped to you like going down like some like boat in a river and Borneo like for
handles like, okay, lit candle. Got it. Yeah. Yeah. Safety meetings over a candle are quite,
they're clearly something. It still gets me to this day. But
I think it's all that under the name of safety because safety never takes a holiday.
So that's right.
Yeah.
好吧，兰德尔，你和格雷格关于该剧的外观风格或保持纪录片风格的早期对话有哪些？你们是否制定了某种拍摄计划以及它会呈现出什么样子？非常有这回事。我看过原版的《办公室》，也就是英国版。当格雷格和我见面时，我向他提出了这个想法。我说这有点像纯素热狗。所以它就像是用垃圾食品包装好的好食物。这有点像，你在它上面涂上一层虚假的清漆，这样人们就会有点倾向于它。
Well, Randall, what were some of the early conversations you had with Greg about the look of the show or preserving the documentary style?
Did you guys have sort of a game plan how you were going to shoot and what it was going to look like?
Very much so.
I saw the original office, you know, the British version.
And when Greg and I met, I pitched him this idea.
I said it's kind of like a tofu hot dog.
So it's like good food that's wrapped like bad food.
And it's kind of, you're putting this fake veneer on it so that people kind of lean in.
我们在《幸存者》和所有我做过的真实纪录片节目中一直做的一件事是，当对话很亲密时，你会从它退开。你不会像普通电视那样走向它。你退开，退开，再退开，因为这会让观众觉得他们知道了一些他们不一定应该知道的事情。所以他们觉得自己融入了这个笑话中。他们觉得自己融入了那个时刻。我认为这增加了一种非常美好的亲密感。作为一名演员，兰德尔，我喜欢你在那些亲密时刻将镜头拉开的方式，因为作为演员最难的事情之一就是将几英寸外的摄像机排除在外。这非常具有解放性。
And the one thing that we always did on shows like Survivor in all reality that I ever did in documentaries is when a conversation is intimate, you back away from it.
You don't go to it, like normal TV.
You back away and you back away and you back away because that makes the viewer think that they're privy to something that they shouldn't necessarily be privy to.
So they feel in on the joke.
They feel in on the moment.
And I think it adds a level of intimacy that is really nice.
As an actor, Randall, I loved how you would back that camera off for those intimate moments because one of the hard things as an actor is blocking out the camera that is inches away from you.
And it was very freeing.
这真的是我最喜欢的体验之一，那些时刻感觉如此私密，因为你们离得更远。是的。是的。是的。自从《办公室》之后，我又出演过一些节目。我拍过一个场景，摄像机是如此之近
It was one of my favorite experiences, really,
is how private those moments really felt
because you guys were further away.
Yeah.
Yes.
I've been on shows now since the office.
I did this scene and the camera was so close
以至于当另一个演员停下来不说话时，我甚至能听到（因为摄像机离得那么近）。而你却试图说：好吧，我和这个人处在当下。是的，我认为把片场留给演员总是有其道理的。作为现在的导演，我总是试图退一步，顺其自然，这不应该成为我的环境。
that when the other actor paused and talking,
I could just hear,
because the camera was that close.
And you're trying to like say,
okay,
I'm in the moment with this other person.
Yeah, I think there's something always to be said for just giving this set to actors.
It's something I, as a director now, I always try to back away and just let it be, it shouldn't be my environment.
这应该是演员的环境。这是我在《办公室》里从一些伟大导演那里绝对学到的东西。好吧，作为一个演员，我喜欢它。是的，我也是。兰德尔，你能跟我们谈谈，当你的角色是摄影指导时，你是如何与导演一起为一个场景做准备的，比如值班室里的一个标准场景，而你不得不拍摄一系列的反应镜头？你是如何做准备的？
It should be the actor's environment.
That's something I absolutely learned on the office from some of the great directors.
Well, as an actor, I love it.
Yeah, me do.
Randall, can you tell us a little bit about how you would prep a scene with a director?
director when you were in the role of cinematographer, like a standard scene in the bullpen,
and you're having to cover a bunch of reactions.
How would you prep that?
对于《办公室》，我们基本上倾向于排练一个场景，演员们会做演员们会做的事。而马特和我就会像这样站在那里，这就是我们的摄像机。马特和我看着对方，好像在说：好的，我搞定这个，我搞定詹娜。太好了。你搞定吉姆。太好了。在詹娜的台词之后，我要摇镜头到吉姆那里。
For the office, we would basically just tend to rehearse a scene and the actors would do what
the actors would do.
And Matt and I would just stand there like this, and this is our camera.
And Matt and I would be looking at each other like, okay, I got this, I got Jenna.
Great.
You've got Jim.
I'm going to do a swing to Jim after Jenna's line.
所以我打算像这样把他们联系起来。马特会蹲下，然后我来拍那个。然后我再站起来，我们俩就会那样站着。如果你看看像《幸存者》这样的节目，比方说，你有两个人谈话，并且有所谓的“脏过肩镜头”（dirty overs），你不一定让那个人的画面保持干净，你试图把他们联系起来。这是我们一直试图做的一件事，即通过将两个角色的画面放在我们的取景框中来展示这种人与人之间的联系。
So I'm going to connect them like that.
and Matt would duck and I would get that.
And then I'd come back up and we would just kind of both stand there.
And if you look at shows like Survivor, let's say,
where you have two people talking and you have what we call dirty overs,
you don't have the person necessarily clean, you try to connect them.
And that was something that we always tried to do is to show that human connection
by placing both characters in both of our frames.
所以马特和我必须互相将对方排除在取景框之外。有时这意味着你需要备份并使用更长的镜头。这样你就看不到马特的肩膀、马特的膝盖或其他什么。所以，是的，我们会坐在那里，我们会对此做出反应。马特和我只会跳这支舞，我们会弄清楚我们的覆盖范围。我记得哈罗德·雷米斯在执导
So Matt and I would have to just frame each other out.
And sometimes that means you need to back up
and get a little bit longer on the lens.
So you don't see Matt's shoulder or Matt's knee or whatever.
So, yeah, we would just sit there and we would react to it.
And Matt and I would just do this dance
where we would figure out what our coverage was.
and I remember Harold Ramos directing
那是最酷的时刻，哈罗德进来了，我的意思是，他提前准备了一个星期，因为他对制作这部节目感到非常兴奋，我记得史蒂夫欣喜若狂。我们在史蒂夫的办公室里拍摄一个场景，他当时说：那正是哈罗德·雷米斯！哈罗德·雷米斯，天哪！
and it was the coolest moment
as Harold came in
I mean he prepped like an extra week
because he was so excited about doing the show
which I just everybody I remember Steve was giddy
we were in Steve's office and doing it
a scene he was that's Harold Ramos right there
Harold Ramos gosh
是的，但我的意思是，哈罗德真的做了充分的准备，他有着所有的计划，就像我精心绘制的那样。我记得我们排练了第一个场景，马特和我只是站在那里，做了这个和那个，讨论了一番，我看着他，他看着我，我们弄清楚了谁将拍摄什么，然后哈罗德走过来，说：
yeah but I mean Harold really really prepped
and he had all those plans like I had
just meticulously drawn out
And I remember we rehearsed the first scene
And Matt and I just kind of stood there and did this and that
And talked it through and I looked at him and he looked at me and
We figured out who was going to get what
And Harold came over and says
我应该扔掉这个，对吧？我说：不，哈罗德，这真的，能和你合作是如此荣幸，是的。别扯淡了，孩子，我应该扔掉这个计划，对吧？你做的事情要好得多。我说：嗯，这是一个很棒路线图，哈罗德，然后你知道的，我们又拍了一个场景，我记得看着他，看着他。
I should just get rid of this right
I'm like no
Harold this really it's such an honor to be working with you and yeah
Don't shit me kid I should get rid of this plan right
This is what you did was way better I'm like well that's a
it's a great road map Harold
and then you know we did one more scene
and I remember watching him looking at him
他引起了我的注意，他只是把他的计划扔进了帕姆的垃圾桶里。我清楚地记得我们当时在哪里，是的，哈罗德·雷米斯把他的镜头计划扔进了帕姆的垃圾桶里，因为他觉得你拍得太棒了。
and he got my attention
he just chucked his plans
in Pam's trash bin
I remember exactly where we were
yeah Harold Ramas
threw his shot plans
into Pam's trash bin
because he thought you nailed it
太棒了，兰德尔，如果换作我，我会说：有人去把那些从垃圾桶里拿出来，我要把它们留着。是的。好吧，我不得不说，我真的很好奇你对那个问题的回答会是什么，因为我的记忆是，大部分情况下，都是你和马特在我们的排练期间想出镜头的。而导演们更专注于演员的表现，给我们笔记，确保我们把笑话讲好，确保编剧们把他们的备用笑话放进去。真的，有一种巨大的信任。
that that's great Randall
that would for me I'd be like
someone go get those out of the trash
I'm saving those
yeah
Yeah. Well, I have to say, I was really curious what your answer was going to be to that question because my memory is that for the most part, it was you and Matt figuring out the shots during our rehearsal. And the directors were more focused on just actor performance, giving us notes, making sure we landed the jokes, making sure that the writers got their alternate jokes in. And really, there was this huge trust.
that you guys knew how to shoot the show.
The directors didn't, for the most part,
那就是你们知道如何拍摄这部剧。导演们在很大程度上没有以任何方式微观管理你们。我不记得任何人告诉过我在这句台词上切到他或错过这句台词。这总是……而且你知道的，当我过去……这也是我至今仍在做的事情。当我与摄像机交谈时，我对摄像机操作员说话就像我对演员说话一样。
like micromanage you in any way.
I don't recall anybody ever telling me
get to him on this line or miss this line.
It was always...
And you know, when I went...
And it's something I still do.
When I'm talking to cameras,
I talk to a camera operator like I'm talking to an actor.
我会说，你这么想，但你也怀疑她可能会那样做。这种做法赋予了摄像机一点视角，这对于《办公室》来说是至关重要的。对于其他节目，我认为这也很有趣，因为你信任摄像机操作员的直觉，并为他们提供了为场景增添技巧的基础，我认为这总是非常有趣的。太美妙了。我喜欢那样。好吧，你知道的，兰德尔，你们非常擅长的另一件事是捕捉那些没有写进剧本的时刻。我认为我们拍摄的方式增加了一种真实感，即兴创作的时刻也是如此。无论我们是否使用即兴创作的时刻，它仍然把每个人都带入了“这一切正在发生”的空间。这是一件真实的事情。
I will say, you think this,
but you also suspect that she might do that.
And that kind of gives the camera a little bit of a point of view, which for the office is paramount.
For other shows, I think is also interesting because you're trusting the intuition of the camera operator and you're giving them the basis to add some finesse to a scene, which I think is always really interesting.
That's beautiful. I love that. Well, you know, Randall, one of the things you guys were also so great at was catching these moments that weren't scripted.
I think that the way we filmed it added a level of authenticity, as did the improvisational moments.
And whether we used improvisational moments or not, it still put everybody in that space of this is happening.
This is a real thing.
这有一种即时性。这不是在排练。这是正在我们面前和我们周围发生的事情。你们所有人都能成为其中的一部分，这太棒了。看到角色们从未出戏，这真是太惊人了。凯文一直都是凯文，安吉拉一直都是安吉拉。在我看来，把这些时刻加入其中，让它感觉像是一个有生命的东西，并以一种真正有意义和重要的方式感觉真实
There's an immediacy to this.
It's not a rehearsing.
It's something that is happening in front of us and around us.
And for you all to be part of that was awesome.
It was amazing to see, you know, characters never drop character.
They just kept Kevin kept being.
Kevin and Angela kept being Angela.
And adding those moments in to me made it feel like a living thing and made it feel real
和有机，从而影响了整体的结果。这太诗意了。这是我听过的关于片场即兴表演最好的回答。好吧，兰德尔，我知道我们大部分时间都把你关在那个装有荧光灯的办公室里。但偶尔我们确实会把你塞进汽车后座，或者把你放在船上。那是什么感觉？对你来说，那些拍摄日是什么样的？
and organic in a really meaningful and significant way that affected the overall outcome.
That is so poetic.
That is the best answer I have ever heard about improv on a set.
Well, Randall, I know that we kept you in that office under the fluorescent light.
most of the time.
But occasionally we did cram you into the backseat of a car or we put you on a boat.
What was it like?
What were those shoot days for you like?
我在很多尴尬的地方拍过笔记，爱因斯坦说过，困难当中蕴藏着机遇。事情越难，效果就越好。就像我回看车里开往湖边的那个场景时。整个过程，我只是在对此做出反应。我记得那些，在所有事情发生的过程中，尽管水涌进来，而且挤在后座上很困难，但当GPS说话时，我把镜头平移到了GPS上，因为它是场景中的一个角色。所以我认为这些机遇以一种非常非常有趣的方式增添了另一个元素。但就像迈克尔的赛百灵（Sebring）一样，
I've shot note in a lot of awkward places, Einstein said, in the midst of difficulty lies
opportunity.
And the harder it got, the better it got.
Like I just rewatch that scene in the car where we're driving to.
the lake. And the whole time, I was just reacting to it. And I remember those, you know, in the midst
of everything happening, as difficult as it was with a water coming in and he cramped in the backseat,
when the GPS spoke, I panned the GPS because it was a character in the scene. So those opportunities,
I think, add another element in a really, really interesting way. But like Michael's Sebring,
他对此非常自豪，那是一辆轿跑车，一辆两门车。所以后座，虽然它是一辆四座车或五座车，但对两座车加一个摄像师来说并不十分舒适，因为我记得摄像机的高度超过了后车窗，因为这是一辆很酷的车，迈克尔，后车窗有很大的倾斜度
which he was so proud of,
it was a coupe, it was a two-door.
So the backseat, although it's a four-seater car
or a five-seater car,
it wasn't a two-seater plus a cameraman
very comfortably because I remember the camera came up higher
than the back window because it was such a cool car, Michael,
that the back window had such a slope to it
以至于我的摄像机总是会撞到后窗。那里有一个变速箱穿过去的隆起，而且真的没有地方可以放你的腿。所以你只能把自己系成一个结，并希望通过这种不适感找到一些机会。你知道的，我，我会晕车。我真的很晕车。什么？是的。
that my camera would always hit the back of the window.
And there was a hump there where the transmission went through
and there's really kind of no place for your legs to go.
So you just kind of tie yourself in a knot and hopefully find some opportunity by that discomfort.
You know, I get I get car sick.
I get really car sick.
What?
Yeah.
每次我从车里出来。你到底是怎么工作的？是的。哦，我的天呐。你真的很晕车？继续说吧。兰德尔，我一点也不知道，因为当我们，很多次我们在车里拍摄时，我们只是兜圈子。我们在绕圈子。
Every time I got out of a car.
How in the world do you do your job?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
You get really car sick?
Go on.
Randall, I had no idea because when we, so many times when we filmed in cars, we just looped.
We did a circle.
而我在绕圈子时会感到恶心。是的。更不用说只用一只眼睛了。是的。不，我真的很晕车。我记得每次克里斯和埃德帮我把沉重的摄像机搬出来，帮我从里面出来时。
And I would get nauseous.
doing the circle.
Yeah.
Let alone only with one eye.
No, I get really car sick.
And I remember every time Chris and Ed were helping me get the heavy camera out and helping
me come out there.
就像，你怎么样？你还好吗？你没事吧？是的，挺好的。而且这种情况会持续几个小时。但我们有那么多，我们有那么多的驾车场景，兰德尔。我从来不知道这一点。是的。
Like, how you doing?
You all right?
You're okay?
Yeah, real good.
And it would last a couple hours.
But we had so many, we had so many driving scenes, Randall.
I never knew this.
Yeah.
哦，天哪。是的。我在后座有时会变得有点发绿。我只是出汗很多。好吧，谢谢你，因为它确实产生了一些惊人的、惊人的效果。那很有趣。我知道我们正在讨论诸如艰难的摄像机位置之类的事情，但是兰德尔，你必须和大家分享一下。
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah.
I was getting a little green at times back there.
I was just kind of sweating a lot.
Well, thank you because it really did produce some amazing, amazing things.
That was fun.
I know we're sort of talking about, like, difficult camera positions and stuff,
but Randall, you have to share with everybody.
你向我们介绍了Poodie Scootie（滑轮凳）。Poodie Scootie。但这是你发明的吗？那是戴尔为你制作的吗？戴尔为我们制作的。我很想坐在演员的高度在办公室里滑行和移动，你知道的，不是在摇臂上。我们只是想保持快捷和敏捷。
You introduced us to the Poodie Scootie.
The Poodie Scootie.
But did you invent that?
Was that something Dale made for you?
Dale made it for us.
I would love to be able to scoot around the office at actor level and move, you know, not like
on a dolly.
And we just wanted to be quick and nimble.
而且也是为了让我能够对此做出反应，而不是与灯光师沟通我需要向后移动一英尺，因为我要向左平移。我们永远也做不到这一点。所以戴尔建造了这些。这太棒了。那东西运作得非常非常顺利。太有趣了。它就像一个滚动的箱子。
And also so that I can react to it as opposed to communicating to a grip that I need to
move back at foot because I'm going to pan to the left.
We never would have gotten there.
So Dale built those.
And that was great.
That thing worked really, really well.
It was so fun.
It was like a rolling box.
然后他们最终在它上面为你弄了一个小垫子。有垫子的。那些日子啊。是的，那些日子。你可以转圈。它有点像凳子，但对你来说比凳子好一点，因为我认为它是方的。是的。你离开办公室时把poodie scutty带走了吗？
And then they eventually got you a little cushion on top of it.
Cushing.
Those are the days.
Yeah, those are the days.
And you could spin around.
It was kind of like a stool, but a little better than a stool for you because I think it was like square.
Yeah.
Did you take the pooty scutty with you when you left the office?
我没有。我没有。你没有。不。没有。从那以后，别人为我制造过其他的poodie scooties，但就是不一样。我想告诉我们观众的一件事是，摄影指导同时操作摄像机是多么的不可思议。听起来，兰德尔，你为了把摄像机永远抓在手里进行了多么激烈的斗争。
I didn't.
You didn't.
No.
And since then I've had other pootie scooties built for me and there just weren't the same.
I feel like something I want to tell our audience is how incredibly rare it is for a cinematographer to also operate the camera.
And it sounds like, Randall, you fought so hard to always keep that camera in your hands.
你不想把它放在支架上。你不想把它放在摇臂上。你就是操作员。在我做过的其他项目中，通常确实是摄影指导直接指挥，而摄像机操作员则不太把手放在摄像机上。这就像一件非常酷的事情。
You did not want to put it on sticks.
You did not want to put it on a dolly.
You were the operator.
And in other projects I've done, it really is usually a cinematographer, direct.
a camera operator
and they
don't put their hands on the camera so much.
It was like this really cool thing.
是的，总有一种脱节的元素，因为在传统的节目中有大约八到十个人专门负责两台摄像机。而在我们的节目中，我们的摄像部门只有四个人。就是我和马特、克里斯和埃德，马特和我自己负责对焦
Yeah, I think there's always an element of disconnect
because on traditional shows
there's like eight to ten people
just who are looking after
two cameras. And on our show,
our camera department was four.
It was me and Matt and Chris and Ed
and Matt and I pulled her own focus
我们自己调整光圈，我会设置摄像机的外观。我会给摄像机编程，设定我们希望它们呈现的效果以及我们希望它们如何匹配。然后剩下的事情都是在后期制作中完成的。但马特和我认为非常重要的一点是
and we pull our own iris,
I would set to look for the cameras.
I would program the cameras
what we wanted them to look like
and how we wanted them to match.
And then the rest of the stuff
was just worked out in post.
But Matt and I thought it was really important
自己对焦并自己调整光圈。我也认为，当操作员是场景的一部分并且也在聆听场景时，同样存在一种亲密感。这是许多节目中并不常见的事情，相当频繁。
to pull her own focus and pull our own iris.
I also think there's, again,
a level of intimacy
when the operator is part of the scene
and is also listening to the scene.
And that's something that doesn't happen
on a lot of shows
is quite often.
许多节目中，摄影指导不听台词。我在想，你怎么知道该做什么？是的。因为在拍摄纪录片的过程中，直到我的录音师把吊杆伸出来说“这是一场相关的对话，你该拍这个，白痴，别拍那个”之前，我都不知道该拍什么。所以我操作时仍然戴着耳机。
A lot of shows, the DP doesn't listen to the words.
And I wonder, how do you know what to do?
Yeah.
Because coming up in documentaries, I didn't know what to shoot until my sound men put the boom up and said,
this is a relevant conversation.
You should be shooting this, idiot.
Don't shoot that.
So I still, when I operate, I wear an earpiece.
所以我能听到正在发生的事情，这样我就可以微调我正在做的事情。好了，兰德尔，有时在我们的片场，事情会变得有点形体化。谁撞了你？你跟谁相撞得最多？你知道的，我想我在火灾那一集里把自己摔倒在地。我记得那件事。我倒退着穿过厨房然后摔倒了。我想我撞到了地面，但我不是很确定。
So I'm hearing what's going on so that I can finesse what I'm doing.
Now, Randall, sometimes on our set, things got a little physical.
Who ran into you?
Who did you collide with the most?
You know, I think I sent myself to the floor in the fire one.
I remember that.
I was backing up through the kitchen and I fell.
And I think I hit the ground, but I'm not real sure.
但我是一个200磅重的人。而摄像机重达38磅。我记得克里斯·沃克曼（Chris Workman），他是一个非常强壮的人，我想他单手就把我提了起来，而我还在继续拍摄。他单手把我提起来，我说：哦，我摔倒了吗？我只是继续拍摄这个场景，因为我想：我想我摔倒了。兰德尔，那是留在正片里的镜头。是的。
But I'm a 200-pound human being.
And the camera is 38 pounds.
And I remember Chris Workman, who was a very strong person,
I think he picked me up with one hand and I just kept rolling.
He just picked me up with one head and I'm like, oh, did I fall?
And I just kept going with the scene because I'm like, I think I fell.
And Randall, that's the footage that stayed in.
Yes.
我们用了你摔倒然后重新站起来的那个镜头。这太不可思议了。我记得当时在那儿，用眼角余光看到了这一幕，心想：我们还在继续吗？因为兰德尔在地上。哦，不，兰德尔站起来了。兰德尔站起来了。好吧。
We use the take of you falling and getting back up.
It was incredible.
I remember being there and seeing it out of the corner of my eye and thinking,
are we still going?
Because Randall is on the floor.
Oh, no, Randall's up.
Randall's up.
All right.
我们要继续。是的。现在是克里斯·沃克曼，就像把我像个小布娃娃一样提起来，而且没有放开我。我一下子又站回脚上了。不管怎样，我记得的一件事是在《日式铁板烧》里，我从Poodie Scootie上摔了下来。
We're going to continue.
Yep.
Now is Chris Workman, just lifting me up like a little round.
bag doll and I'm not letting me go.
I was just back on my feet.
Anyway, one thing
I remember is in Benihana, I
fell on the Poodie Scootie.
我记得我看到的最后一幕是史蒂夫大喊：不！总是那样。总是史蒂夫对你喊“不”。我想问这个问题。除了在那个场景中救了你的命之外，克里斯·沃克曼还
I remember the last thing I saw was Steve just going,
no!
And it was always that.
It was always Steve like, no,
about you.
I want to ask this question.
In addition to saving your life
in that scene, Chris Workman also
过去经常给你带这种饮料。在片场。安吉拉和我都想了解更多。它看起来像是水果和水。这是什么饮料？这是你特殊的摄像机操作员燃料吗？你看，这就是在泰国炎热的阳光下拍摄海滩上的人与在办公室里的区别。我不会得到同类型的饮料。在那里。你知道，那是福利之一。福利之一。第三季，我会有，我喜欢气泡水。是的，我要说的是，我记得那是忙碌的。
used to bring you
this drink.
on set. And Angela and I need to know more about it. It looked like it was like fruit and water.
What was this drink? Was this your special camera operator fuel? You see, that's the difference
between being out in the hot sun and Thailand and shooting people on a beach and being in the office.
I would not get the same type of beverages. Out there. You know, that was one of the perks. One of the
Perks. Season three, I would have, I would have them, I liked bubbly water.
Yes, I was going to say, I remember it was busy.
是的，我听起来像个讲究的人。我喜欢气泡水，我会让克里斯把水果捣碎放进我的水里。所以我会有真正水果味的气泡水。如果这都不算生活，这不算是成功的标志，那我不知道什么才算。我喜欢它。克里斯有一次给我做了一个，因为我说：克里斯，我们在哪儿？像，我们一直在给兰德尔带？我在。然后他悄悄地把一杯滑到我的桌上。我说，太清爽了。兰德尔，我支持你。
Yeah, I sound like such a fancy man. I like bubbly water, and I would have Chris bruised the fruit and put it in my water for me.
And so I would have real fruit flavored bubbly water. Now, if that's not living, that's not a sign of success, I don't know what it is.
I love it. Chris made me one one time because I was like, Chris, we're at.
like, we keep bringing Randall?
I'm on.
And then he just sort of slyly slid one on my desk.
I was like, it was so refreshing.
I stand by at Randall.
我认为这是一个明智的举动。而且你坐在你的poodie scootie上喝着气泡水，一点也不做作。好吧，兰德尔，我们确实会问我们的嘉宾这个。节目杀青时，你拍完时，你从片场拿了什么东西吗？我们都拿了一点小东西。你拿了什么吗？
I think it's a great move.
And you're not,
you're not too fancy on your poody, scooty with your bubbly water.
Yeah.
Okay, Randall, we do ask our guest this.
Did you take anything from the set when the show wrapped, when you were done?
We all took a little something.
Did you take something?
我没有。我没有拿任何东西。什么？兰德尔。我一直期盼着第10季，所以我只是不想破坏那个并确保我没有搞砸。如果我拿了一个我们用过的笔筒，（你知道的）我们就不会回来了。我没有。
I didn't.
I didn't take anything.
What?
Randall.
I was always hoping for a season 10,
so I just didn't want to preserve that and make sure that I didn't screw it up.
And if I took a pencil holder that we, you know, we wouldn't come back.
I didn't.
我发誓我什么都没拿。现在回想起来，如果你能拿点什么，你会拿什么？是的，我想大概是写着我名字的牌匾吧。我觉得那个挺酷的。我不知道我会拿什么。火灾里的烤箱。好吧，给你。
I didn't take anything.
I swear.
In hindsight now, if you could have taken something, what would you have taken?
Yeah, I suppose my plaque with my name on it.
I think that was pretty cool.
I don't know what I would take.
Toaster oven from the fire.
Yeah, there you go.
不错。好吧，我们应该和我们的听众分享一下。我想，（你知道的）很多《办公室》的粉丝会知道这一点，那就是兰德尔，你后来成了一位多产的导演，你在导演各种各样的精彩节目。我在办公室之后在《维尔弗雷德》里和你合作过。那真的很有趣。一个奇怪的小节目。奇怪的小节目。但这是一群非常有趣的人。
Nice.
Well, we should share it with our listeners.
And I think, you know, a lot of Office Ladies fans will know this, that Randall, you went on and now are a prolific director and you're directing all kinds of amazing shows.
And I got to work with you post office on Wilfred.
That was really fun.
A weird little show.
Weird little show.
But such a fun group of people.
我当时只在那儿待了一天，但我很喜欢那个片场的氛围。但正如孩子们所说，你现在正大获成功。兰德尔，你有什么即将推出的项目或者有什么我们可以分享给每个人去关注的东西吗？我不如以前那么经常执导了。我有一个全面发展协议。所以我正在为ABC进行开发。开发非常酷。我喜欢开发。所以我们将期待你的项目问世。我等不及了。兰德尔，你那双闪亮的蓝眼睛看起来真让人高兴。两只都是。我们通常只看到一只，但两只都太棒了。是的，兰德尔，非常感谢你
I was just there one day, but I loved the vibe on that set.
But you are, you are just out there crushing it as the kids say.
Randall, do you have any upcoming projects or anything we can share with everyone to check out?
I don't direct as much as I used to. I have an overall development deal. So I'm developing for ABC.
Development is very cool. I love development. So we will be looking for your projects coming out. And I can't wait.
Randall, your sparkly blue eye is a delight to see. Both of them. We normally saw one of them, but both of them are wonderful to see.
Yes, Randall, thank you so much.
for taking this time to deep dive with us.
花时间与我们深度交流。
I've been so looking forward to this.
And thank you, too, for letting us email you
and for when you've hopped on the phone with me
to tell me tidbits behind the scenes.
You've helped me make this podcast even better.
So thank you.
Thank you.
It was a really special time.
我一直非常期待这一次。也谢谢你让我们给你发邮件，谢谢你在我和你通电话时告诉我幕后的花絮。你帮助我让这个播客变得更好了。所以谢谢你。谢谢。那是一段非常特殊的时光。
And to get to relive it, I'll do that any chance I get.
So keep calling.
Well, we will.
I was about to say, Jenna, we're not done calling him.
It's nice that you're thanking him, but we have a lot more to ask you over these next,
I don't know how many episodes.
Two more years.
There's one thing I'd love to say.
能重温它，我随时乐意。所以继续打电话吧。好吧，我们会 的。我正要说，詹娜，我们还没打完电话呢。你感谢他是很好，但我们在接下来的（我不知道是多少集）里还有很多问题要问你。还有两年。有一件事我很想说。
Yes.
I remember when I first started getting in directing, Greg Daniels is absolutely how I got him directing.
Greg came to me when I were shooting the office.
He says, you're telling jokes with the cameras.
Thank you.
Yes, I am.
I'm trying to.
He says, you should direct some.
是的。我记得我刚开始涉足导演工作时，格雷格·丹尼尔斯绝对是我走上导演之路的关键。当我正在拍摄《办公室》时，格雷格来到我身边。他说：你正在用摄像机讲笑话。谢谢。是的，我是。我在努力。他说：你应该导演一些。
Like, that sounds cool.
Yeah, I'd love to.
And Greg gave me the opportunity to start to.
directing. And I remember that the cast was everybody was so supportive. Everybody wanted to see me
succeed. And that meant a lot. That meant a lot to feel so supported and have everybody
ensuring that I succeeded and were in collaborating with me. And that was very, very special.
And then I remember when I wanted to start to do more directing elsewhere, and I think the first
thing I did was it's always sunny in Philadelphia. And I remember, wow, I'm going to, I'm going to ask
我说，听起来很酷。是的，我很乐意。然后格雷格给了我开始执导的机会。我记得演员阵容中的每个人都非常支持。每个人都希望看到我成功。这意味着很多。能够得到如此多的支持，并让每个人都确保我取得成功并与我合作，这意味着很多，而且非常非常特别。然后我记得当我想开始在其他地方做更多导演工作时，我想我做的第一件事是《费城永远阳光灿烂》。我记得，哇，我要去，我要去
Greg if I can go direct another show. And I remember Greg's response was, absolutely, yeah, that's
fantastic. You just totally go do that. You should definitely go direct some other shows. And when you
come back, we'll be here. We'll be here. We'll open arms. Just go direct other shows and come back
to us when you can. And who does that? Nobody does that. Nobody does that.
not in Hollywood. Nobody does not in Hollywood. How's Greg? Yeah. Greg was always very, very,
very excited for us to broaden our horizons. And he was so encouraging of us all as artists to meet that
next new milestone. And you're right. Like, you don't, you don't find that a lot. He's also so
generous. And, you know, even still, when Jen and I were going to do this podcast, you know,
问问格雷格我是否可以去导演另一个节目。我记得格雷格的回答是：当然可以，是的，太棒了。你完全可以去。你绝对应该去导演一些其他的节目。等你回来后，我们会在这里。我们会敞开双臂在这里。只要去导演其他节目，然后在你能回来的时候回到我们身边。谁会这样做？没有人会这样做。没有人会这样做。好莱坞可没有这样的人。好莱坞没有这样的人。格雷格怎么样？是的。格雷格总是非常非常非常为我们开拓视野而感到兴奋。作为艺术家，他非常鼓励我们所有人去迎接下一个新的里程碑。你说得对。就像，你不会，你不会经常发现这一点。他也是如此慷慨。而且，（你知道的）甚至现在，当詹娜和我要做这个播客时，（你知道的）
we were like, gosh, you know, we're not the experts on the office. We're not. We're just two gals
who became best friends doing this fantastic, amazing show. And he was like, I love it.
Like, he was so supportive. Yeah. Yeah. He was like, ask me any questions. You want me to send you
pictures? I've got pictures from the pilot. Yeah. We were like, yeah. He's so caring and supportive
of our office family.
Whatever it is we're doing,
he's going to watch it, he'll tell you his thoughts on it,
he'll answer questions for you,
我们当时想，天哪，（你知道的）我们不是《办公室》的专家。我们不是。我们只是两个通过制作这部精彩、美妙的剧集而成为最好朋友的姑娘。而他的反应是：我喜欢它。就像，他是如此支持。是的。是的。他说：随便问我什么问题。你想要我给你发照片吗？我有试播集的照片。是的。我们当时想，耶。他对我们的办公室家族如此关怀和支持。无论我们做什么，他都会看，他会告诉你他对它的想法，他会为你解答问题，
and it is special.
It is really special.
We all made it special, but Greg was absolutely,
he was set in a very, very fine example
by his inclusive attitude.
Anybody's idea was worth here for Greg.
It's a good guy.
You're a good guy, buddy.
这很特别。这真的很特别。我们所有人都让它变得特别，但格雷格绝对，他通过他的包容态度树立了一个非常好、非常好的榜样。在格雷格看来，任何人的想法都值得在这里被倾听。是个好人。你是个好人，老兄。
You are.
And Randall, we definitely will have you back.
we want you to come break down one of the episodes that you directed.
I'd love to. That sounds fun.
Oh, good.
All right, Randall.
Take care.
Nice to hang out with you all.
你确实是。兰德尔，我们肯定会再请你来。我们想让你来剖析你导演过的其中一集。我很乐意。听起来很有趣。太好了。好吧，兰德尔。保重。和你们大家一起玩得很开心。
Thank you.
All right.
Bye-bye.
This spring, denim gets a softer, lighter update.
Introducing Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg,
a new fit that moves with you.
It's everything you want denim to feel like for summer.
Easy, breathable, and effortlessly cool.
谢谢。好的，再见。今年春天，牛仔布迎来了更柔软、更轻盈的焕新。隆重推出Old Navy的垂坠牛仔阔腿裤，这是一种随你而动的全新版型。这是你对夏天牛仔布的所有期望。轻松、透气且毫不费力地展现酷炫。
With a fit that creates natural movement and a wide leg that feels
modern, not overwhelming. Plus, that signature, wait, for this price, moment. Old Navy's drapey denim
wide leg. Oh my gosh, Angela. So great getting to see Randall over Zoom. And guys, we'll post a
picture of that on Office Ladies' Pod so you can see the blue eyes we spoke so much about.
Yes. And just like the cool vibe, Randall always has. Oh, yeah. Randall, thank you. That was fantastic.
All right, well, lady, let's get started breaking down the second half of season three, starting with Back from Vacation.
We've got some spam news.
Yes, we do.
拥有能营造自然律动的版型，以及现代感十足却又不显突庸的阔腿。还有那个标志性的“等等，这个价格？”的时刻。Old Navy的垂坠牛仔阔腿裤。天哪，安吉拉。在Zoom上看到兰德尔真是太棒了。伙计们，我们会在Office Ladies Pod上发布一张照片，这样你们就能看到我们赞不绝口的那双蓝眼睛了。是的。就像兰德尔一贯的酷炫风格一样。哦，是的。兰德尔，谢谢你。太棒了。好吧，女士们，让我们开始剖析第三季的后半部分，从《度假归来》开始。我们有一些关于垃圾邮件（Spam）的新闻。是的，我们有。
You guys might remember that spam featured very heavily in this episode.
Michael throws a party in the warehouse and he tells the party planning committee he wants a pig.
But all they can find is spam.
And we had a lot of questions about spam as we were breaking down this episode.
And thankfully, we got a lot of mail.
Angela,
Yes.
Did you know that spam is a popular food in Hawaii?
你们可能还记得垃圾邮件在这集里占据了非常重要的地位。迈克尔在仓库里举办了一个派对，他告诉派对筹备委员会他想要一头猪。但他们能找到的只有垃圾邮件。当我们剖析这一集时，我们对垃圾邮件有很多疑问。谢天谢地，我们收到了很多邮件。安吉拉，是的。你知道垃圾邮件是夏威夷很受欢迎的食物吗？
According to Kristen, Ordoe, and Viola Lee.
I did know that, but yes, ladies.
Andrea Richardson wrote in to say that Spam was introduced to Hawaii, Guam, and the other Pacific
islands during World War II, because soldiers received it to eat in place of fresh meat.
And it has been a staple of the Hawaiian diet ever since.
She said that at one point there was even a widespread hoarding of spam and toilet paper for fear that shipments would stop when the war ended.
Hmm.
Huh.
根据克里斯汀、奥尔多和维奥拉·李的说法。我知道这一点，但是是的，女士们。安德烈·理查森（Andrea Richardson）写信说，垃圾邮件是在二战期间被引入夏威夷、关岛和其他太平洋岛屿的，因为士兵们收到它是为了代替新鲜肉类食用。从那以后，它一直是夏威夷饮食的主食。她说，有一次甚至出现了广泛囤积垃圾邮件和卫生纸的情况，因为担心战争结束时货运会停止。嗯。
Toilet paper hoarding.
That sounds familiar.
Trigger warning.
Yes.
And this is maybe the biggest news, Angela.
Peggy S.
and Emily Childs said there is a spam museum in Austin Hastings, Minnesota.
I know that.
囤积卫生纸。听起来很熟悉。触发警告。是的。这也许是最大的新闻，安吉拉。佩吉·S和艾米丽·柴尔兹说，在明尼苏达州奥斯汀·黑斯廷斯有一个垃圾邮件博物馆。我知道那个。
You want to know how I know?
You know there's a spam museum in Minnesota?
Yes.
How do you know?
Okay, this is awesome.
Listen to this.
We got the loveliest letter from two sisters who are from Austin, Minnesota.
I want to give a shout out to Laura and Amanda Instead.
你想知道我是怎么知道的吗？你知道明尼苏达州有一个垃圾邮件博物馆吗？是的。你怎么知道的？好吧，这太棒了。听这个。我们收到了来自明尼苏达州奥斯汀的两姐妹的极其可爱的信。我要向劳拉和阿曼达·因斯特德（Laura and Amanda Instead）致以谢意。
Who said that Austin is the birthplace of spam?
And in fact, the town is nicknamed Spamtown USA.
They wrote this, and I quote, in the spirit of the podcast, let's start with.
a couple of fast facts.
How cute are these girls? I love it.
They're going to give us some fast facts. I'm going to read them off.
Ready?
Yes.
她们说奥斯汀是垃圾邮件的发源地。事实上，这个小镇的绰号是“美国垃圾邮件镇”。她们写道，我引用一下：“本着播客的精神，让我们从几个冷知识开始。”这些女孩多可爱啊。我太喜欢了。她们要给我们提供一些冷知识。我要把它们读出来。准备好了吗？是的。
Fast fact number one.
On the days when spam is being processed, everyone in town wakes up to the smell of bacon
wafting over from the factory.
Oh my gosh.
Michael would love that.
Michael would have never burnt his foot on a George Foreman grill if he just lived in
Austin, Minnesota.
I know.
冷知识一。在加工垃圾邮件的日子里，镇上的每个人都是伴随着飘过工厂的培根香味醒来的。哦，天哪。迈克尔会喜欢那个的。如果迈克尔住在明尼苏达州的奥斯汀，他就绝对不会在乔治·福尔曼烤架上烫伤他的脚了。我知道。
Michael should have moved there instead of Colorado.
Fast fact number two.
Apart from the link.
scent of bacon, spam plays a role in our lives in other ways like our yearly spam jam festival.
And the creative ways local restaurants incorporate spam into their menus.
I am going to a spam jam festival.
You are going.
We are going.
迈克尔本应该搬到那里而不是科罗拉多。冷知识二。除了挥之不去的培根香味之外，垃圾邮件还在其他方面在我们的生活中发挥作用，比如我们一年一度的垃圾邮件狂欢节（spam jam festival）。以及当地餐馆将垃圾邮件融入其菜单的创意方式。我要去参加垃圾邮件狂欢节。你要去了。我们要去了。
We are adding the spam museum to our list.
Yes, but we have to go to the festival.
Well, yeah, we got to go for spam jam and then go tour the museum.
I love it.
Fast fact number three, 90% of spam.
in 1941 went to the war effort, our dad always tells anyone who will listen that, quote,
we wouldn't have made it through the war without spam.
Those are amazing spam.
我们要把垃圾邮件博物馆加入我们的名单。是的，但我们必须去参加那个节日。好吧，是的，我们得去参加垃圾邮件狂欢节，然后再去参观博物馆。我太喜欢了。冷知识三，1941年90%的垃圾邮件都用于战争努力，我们的爸爸总是对任何愿意听的人说，“如果没有垃圾邮件，我们是不可能渡过战争难关的。”这些都是惊人的垃圾邮件。
Fast facts.
Laura, Amanda, thank you.
Apples.
Applaus.
And I want you guys to know, Laura and Amanda sent me spam socks.
Okay?
They have like a little spam.
I love them.
冷知识。劳拉、阿曼达，谢谢你们。掌声。掌声。我想让你们知道，劳拉和阿曼达给我寄了垃圾邮件袜子。好吗？上面有小小的垃圾邮件。我太喜欢了。
I've already worn them.
They sent you a spam hat.
So I've got to bring it over to you.
and they sent us a photo at the Spam Museum.
We're going to put it in Office Ladies' Pod Insta Stories.
All right. Here's our list. Are you ready?
Okay.
SAS Shoe Factory Tour.
我已经穿过它们了。她们给你寄了一顶垃圾邮件帽子。所以我得把它拿给你。她们还寄给我们一张在垃圾邮件博物馆的照片。我们会把它发到Office Ladies Pod的快拍里。好吧。这是我们的清单。你们准备好了吗？好吧。SAS鞋厂之旅。
Got it.
Hers Chip Factory Tour.
That watermark paper factory in Italy.
Yes.
Spam Museum.
Oh, and Yacht Factory.
And should we go fishing with a Bassmaster?
100%.
明白了。赫尔斯薯片厂之旅。意大利的那家水印造纸厂。是的。垃圾邮件博物馆。哦，还有游艇厂。我们应该和低音钓鱼大师去钓鱼吗？100%。
Get me a Zerapubupy on the line.
Let's do it.
All right.
I don't even know what that is.
I just remember that guy I dated in college, had a zero puppy or something when he went fishing, I think.
What's a zero puppy?
I don't know.
I think it was a hook that looked like a little fish that flopped around.
给我连线一个“零小狗”（Zerapubupy）。我们上吧。好吧。我甚至不知道那是什么。我只记得我在大学约会过的那个人，他去钓鱼时带了一个零小狗或类似的东西，我想。什么是零小狗？我不知道。我想那是一个看起来像个四处扑腾的小鱼的鱼钩。
Here's what I hear when you say that.
I hear zero puppy.
Zero puppy.
Give me a zero puppy.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Well, I don't know who's in charge of these kinds of things, but somewhere out there,
someone would want to like finance our factory tour.
当我听到你这么说时，我听到的是：零小狗。零小狗。给我一个零小狗。我不知道。我完全不知道。好吧，我不知道是谁在负责这类事情，但在某个地方，会有人想要资助我们的工厂之旅。
Nat Geo! Nat Geo!
Nat Geo! Call us!
Jenna, we could do a whole factories around the world with Jen and Angela.
Call us. We're in. We can do it.
Somebody must know someone there.
Tell them. I would watch that show.
Okay, lady, I think now you have some background catches for this episode.
I do. I'm going to hit you up with them.
国家地理！国家地理！国家地理！给我们打电话！詹娜，我们可以和詹娜和安吉拉一起做一个世界各地的工厂之旅。给我们打电话。我们加入。总得有人认识那里的人。告诉他们。我会看那个节目的。好吧，女士们，我想你现在有这一集的背景彩蛋了。我有。我要把它们抛给你们。
All right. Christine Bird said at 12 minutes, 11 seconds, is Michael sitting in his office holding a bottle of chocolate sauce?
Yes, great catch. I went back to this episode. I went right to that time code. It looks like a bottle of Hershey's chocolate sauce. Like he's got it turned around so you don't see the label. He's holding that in one hand. But then if you look, there is the cap of it on his desk. Was he going to take a big swig out of it? But then Dwight interrupted him. Like, oh, that's good.
I screen grabbed it. I'll put it in stories. Well, Rebecca Lee has a palm tree siting at five minutes, four seconds when the group is all out in the parking lot.
And Samantha Tucker saw Palm Tree at 7 minutes 21 seconds.
Melissa C wrote in to say that she is obsessed with looking for palm trees now because you guys remember we did not shoot this show in Scranton.
We shot it in Southern California.
Yeah.
And we tried to remove all our palm trees using CGI in post, but we did not always get them.
好吧。克里斯汀·伯德（Christine Bird）说，在12分11秒时，迈克尔坐在他的办公室里拿着一瓶巧克力酱吗？是的，好彩蛋。我回看这一集。我直接跳到了那个时间码。它看起来像是一瓶好时巧克力酱。就像他把它转过去了，所以你看不到标签。他一只手里拿着那个。但如果你仔细看，他的桌上有它的瓶盖。他是打算大口喝一口吗？但后来德怀特打断了他。就像，哦，那挺好。我截了屏。我会把它发到快拍里。丽贝卡·李（Rebecca Lee）在5分4秒时发现了一棵棕榈树，当时大家都在停车场。萨曼莎·塔克（Samantha Tucker）在7分21秒时看到了一棵棕榈树。梅丽莎·C（Melissa C）写信说，她现在沉迷于寻找棕榈树，因为你们还记得我们没有在斯克兰顿拍摄这部剧，我们在南加州拍摄的。是的。我们试图在后期的CGI中删除我们所有的棕榈树，但我们并没有总是把它们除干净。
So Melissa C would like to propose a new element to our rewatch called Palm Tree Spotter.
Oh, Melissa, I like it.
I want to give a shout out to the underscore photographer.
They shared some great details with us about the steel drum that Michael is playing when he sings feeling hot, hot, hot.
They said it's actually called a steel pan and is the national instrument of Trinidad and Tobago.
Steel pan musicians are called Panis, and it's widely regarded as the only major musical instrument to be invented in the 20th century.
Wow.
Good fast back there.
所以梅丽莎·C想要为我们的重温提出一个新元素，叫做“棕榈树搜寻者”。哦，梅丽莎，我喜欢它。我要向_photographer致以谢意。他们和我们分享了一些关于迈克尔在唱《感觉火辣辣》时演奏的钢鼓的精彩细节。他们说它实际上被称为钢盘（steel pan），是特立尼达和多巴哥的国器。钢盘音乐家被称为Panists，它被广泛认为是在20世纪发明的唯一主要乐器。哇。那里真是一个好冷知识。
I like that.
Right. Well, moving on to traveling salesmen.
Lady, we got a lot of mail about laundry and betrayal.
Yes, we did.
We went on quite a tangent in this episode.
Yeah.
Shauna Z said, I have never laughed so hard at a podcast as I did last night driving home when you guys were talking about funeral poses.
I spit tea all over my steering wheel and windshield.
我喜欢那个。好吧，接下来是《旅行推销员》。女士们，我们收到了很多关于洗衣和背叛的邮件。是的，我们收到了。我们在这一集里离题万里。肖娜·Z（Shauna Z）说，昨晚开车回家时，当你们谈到葬礼姿势时，我从来没有像那样在播客上笑得这么厉害。我把茶喷得到处都是方向盘和挡风玻璃上。
F you, Larry.
I'm so sorry we made you spit out your.
tea, but I'm glad you enjoyed it. And Angela C. said, please make laundry and betrayal into something
real. I mean, it would be kind of fun if we wrote a like limited laundry and betrayal series and did it as a
podcast. Amazing. We could get all of our friends to like hop on and play roles. It'd be so great.
Well, for those of you who haven't heard what we're talking about, the whole Larry and Marjorie bit,
you can go to this episode, Traveling Salesman, go to one hour, two minutes, and 20 seconds. And you will
here the whole thing. All right, well, let's move on to the return, which featured an interview with
去你的，拉里。我很抱歉我们让你喷出了茶，但我很高兴你喜欢它。安吉拉·C（Angela C）说，请把洗衣和背叛变成真正的东西吧。我是说，如果我们写一个类似于《洗衣和背叛》的有限剧集并把它作为播客制作，那将会很有趣。太惊人了。我们可以让所有的朋友都来客串并扮演角色。那太棒了。好吧，对于那些还没听过我们在谈论什么的人，整个拉里和马乔里的桥段，你可以去看这一集《旅行推销员》，来到1小时2分钟20秒。你就会听到整段内容。好吧，让我们继续看《归来》，其中包含了对
Ed Helms. So wonderful. So wonderful. A lot of people were curious why we didn't ask Ed how he
came to be on the office when we did our interview with him, because we usually lead with that.
Yes. Well, that is because we covered Ed's origin story in the merger. So if any of you missed
that and you're wondering, I had interviewed Ed off air for the merger and Angela, you talked with
Rashida because those were the episodes where their characters first appeared. And I told his whole
audition story in that episode, The Merger. So you can go back and check it out. Here's a fan favorite
moment we failed to mention. Several people wrote in about the scene with Ryan and the lemonade.
Brianna said, if you ladies revisited season three, I wanted to say the moment in the episode at
埃德·赫尔姆斯的采访。太棒了。太棒了。很多人很好奇为什么我们在对他的采访中没有问埃德他是如何加入《办公室》的，因为我们通常以这个开始。是的。好吧，那是因为我们在《合并》那一集里讲过埃德的起源故事。所以如果你们任何人错过了那个并且想知道，我曾在《合并》之前私下采访过埃德，而安吉拉，你和拉什达交谈过，因为那是他们角色首次出现的剧集。我在那一集《合并》中讲述了他整个试镜的故事。所以你可以回去查看一下。这里有一个我们没能提及的粉丝最喜欢的时刻。几个人写信谈到了瑞安和柠檬水的那个场景。布里安娜说，如果女士们重温了第三季，我想说的是，在这一集16分57秒时，瑞安在柠檬水上画了一个波浪号和一个重音符号。然后他随后的表情可能是整部剧里我最喜欢的笑话。你还记得这个吗，詹娜？好吧。所以在《归来》中，奥斯卡从因迈克尔的无礼行为而获得的带薪假期中回来了。迈克尔对奥斯卡的回归大惊小怪。他真的希望奥斯卡感到受欢迎。
16 minutes, 57 seconds, where Ryan draws a till day and an accent on the lemonade.
And then his face after was probably my favorite joke of the whole show.
Do you remember this, Jenna?
Okay.
So in the return, Oscar is back from his paid vacation that he was given because of Michael's
offensive behavior.
And Michael is going overboard with Oscar being back.
He really wants him to feel welcome.
所以他决定，当然我们必须为他办个派对。迈克尔说他希望这是一个——我引述一下——“对奥斯卡的庆祝活动”，一个“奥斯卡之夜”，他希望它是针对奥斯卡的，他希望庆祝奥斯卡的墨西哥性。所以在16分56秒时，你看到派对筹备委员会。他们正试图用迈克尔荒谬的指令来装饰会议室。
So he decides, of course, we have to throw him a party.
Michael says he wants it to be, and I'm quoting, a celebration of Oscar.
and Oscar night that he wants it to be Oscar specific
and that he wants to celebrate Oscars Mexicanity.
So at 16 minutes, 56 seconds,
you see the party planning committee.
They're trying to decorate the conference room
using Michael's ridiculous instructions.
他们不知道该怎么办。瑞安拿着一把黑色记号笔，在那个大瓶柠檬水（苏打水瓶）的“n”上面画了一个波浪号，在“e”上面画了一个重音符号。是的。他看着镜头说，我不知道。然后他把它放在一个写着“墨西哥柠檬水”的牌子旁边。我完全忘记了那个时刻。所以，布里安娜，谢谢你把它提出来。
They don't know what to do.
Ryan is using a Sharpie and he puts a tilde over the inn
and an accent over the E on the big like, you know,
bottle of lemonade, the soda bottle.
Yes.
And he looks to camera and he's like,
I don't know. And he sets it down next to a sign that says Mexican lemonade.
I had completely forgotten about that moment. So, Brianna, thank you for bringing it up to the top.
许多人还写信说，他们希望我们讨论这一集中菲利斯的这段独白。是的。我非常喜欢，而且没能讨论让我感到沮丧。这就是菲利斯那句名言所在的剧集，她说德怀特有个大个性，我也有个大个性，有时当两个这样的人聚在一起时，可能会具有爆炸性。太棒了。我们的编剧太擅长塑造我们的角色了。太棒了，但我告诉你，我昨天给菲利斯发了短信，告诉她从她嘴里说出来的一切简直都是黄金。
A lot of people also wrote in to say that they wished we had discussed this Phyllis talking head from this episode.
Yes.
Which I love and I'm bummed we didn't.
This is the episode where Phyllis famously says Dwight has a big personality and I have a big personality.
and sometimes when two people like that get together, it can be explosive.
So good.
Our writers were so good at writing our characters.
So good, but I'm telling you, I actually texted Phyllis yesterday and just told her everything that comes out of her mouth is just gold.
到目前为止，她在我们的重温中是我最喜欢的。她是我最倾向于关注的人。我太喜欢她了。我们最近以家庭为单位看了《头脑特工队》。哦。而菲利斯就是那个可爱的、小小的悲伤角色，在女孩的大脑里。她在里面也太棒了。
She is my favorite in this rewatch so far.
She's who I gravitate towards.
I just love her.
We recently watched Inside Out as a family.
Aw.
And Phyllis is the love.
little sad character in the girl's brain.
She is so good in that, too.
她是其中的核心。是的。她在里面让我哭了。是的。那是我们家最喜欢的电影之一。好吧，在这集中，德怀特去史泰博（Staples）上班了。我们收到了来自Elvira Lynn 84的一条粉丝彩蛋，我非常喜欢。
She's the heart of that.
Yeah.
She made me cry in that.
That's like a family favorite of ours.
All right.
Well, in this episode, Dwight goes to work at Staples.
And we had a fan catch from Elvira Lynn 84 that I loved.
在9分23秒时，在史泰博与德怀特交谈的那位女士由夏洛特·斯图尔特（Charlotte Stuart）饰演，她曾在《草原小屋》中扮演比德尔小姐。我们还听到了杰西·M（Jesse M）的来信，她说她也注意到了这一点。这可能是一个只有老一辈人才能欣赏的有趣事实。伙计们，在这场大流行期间，我的家人重温了《草原小屋》。你知道的，我从小看它长大。我对《草原小屋》的记忆就像是，那个婴儿在平安夜发烧了。
At 9 minutes 23 seconds, the woman in Staples that's talking with Dwight was played by Charlotte
Stuart who played Ms. Beatle on Little House in the Prairie.
We also heard from Jesse M. who said, she noticed this as well.
It might be a fun fact that only an older generation can appreciate.
Guys, during this pandemic, my family did a rewatch of Little House on the Prairie.
You know, I watched it growing up.
And my memories of Little House on the Prairie are like, the baby got a fever on Christmas
Eve.
而保罗不得不冒着暴雨出门。而内莉总是那么刻薄，这经得起时间的检验吗？它确实经得起时间的检验，在当前时期看它是一件非常诡异的事情。因为就像这个家庭一样，他们只是独自呆在他们的小农舍里。孩子们必须互相成为朋友。这只是家庭单位。有点像全都卡在里面。
And Paul had to go out in the rainstorm.
and Nellie was always being mean and did it hold up?
It does hold up,
and it's a really weird thing to watch during current times.
Because like this family, they're just on their own in their little farmhouse.
And the kids have to be friends with each other.
And it's just the family unit.
Kind of all stuck together inside.
是的。每隔一段时间，保罗会冒险去镇上一趟，他会带回一些特殊的零食。这一切都非常令人兴奋。我觉得这非常具有共鸣。我必须指出一件事。写信的杰西，她的资料上写着她，我引述一下，“靠巧克力驱动”。这真的让我大笑。杰西，我懂你。
Yes.
And every once in a while, Paul will venture off to town and he'll bring back some special treat.
And it's all very exciting.
I felt how I'm that very relatable.
And I have to point out something.
Jessie, who wrote in, her profile says she is, quote, fueled by chocolate.
And that really made me laugh.
Jesse, I feel you.
我懂你。我也看到了。杰西，我们支持你。我们还收到了很多关于吉姆和帕姆对安迪恶作剧的邮件。现在，如果你想查看，这个场景从13分24秒开始。詹娜，如果你还记得的话，我们有点
I feel you.
I saw that too.
Jesse, we're with you.
We also got a lot of mail about the gym and Pam prank on Andy.
Now, this scene starts at 13 minutes 24 seconds if you want to check it out.
Jenna, if you remember, we kind of.
made fun. You and I of Jim and Pam's lame spy skills, right? Yes. We had said that we thought it was
silly that Jim went to all the effort to sneakily steal Andy's cell phone to then just hand it off
取笑了——你和我——吉姆和帕姆拙劣的间谍技能，对吧？是的。我们曾说过，我们认为吉姆费尽心思偷偷拿走安迪的手机，然后把它交给帕姆，而帕姆几分钟后（你知道的）站起来，然后她和吉姆穿过值班室，她又把它还给他，这很傻。对吧？为什么？好吧，许多人不同意我们的看法，他们有自己的理论。
to Pam, who then moments later, you know, gets up and then her and Jim walk through the bullpen
and she hands it back to him. Right. Why? Well, many people disagreed with us, and they had some
theories of their own. Well, Anna White said she thinks Jim gives the phone to Pam.
so that Pam can get Andy's cell phone number off the phone in the first place.
Because how else would Jim know?
She thinks Pam probably emails Jim the number so that he can start calling it after he puts it in the ceiling.
Mm-hmm.
好吧，安娜·怀特（Anna White）说她认为吉姆把手机给帕姆是为了让帕姆首先从手机上弄到安迪的手机号码。因为吉姆怎么会知道呢？她认为帕姆可能给吉姆发电子邮件把号码发给他，这样他在把它塞进天花板后就可以开始拨打它了。嗯-hmm。嗯-hmm。
Well, my one thought is Andy is the type of guy that gave every single person his cell phone number the first day.
But that doesn't mean they saved it.
That's true.
But I just have this feeling that Andy has texted Jim, like,
what up my dog big tuna want to meet me for a beer big tuna you're going to answer big tuna look at this
crazy thing I saw on the internet big tuna well I like these theories but I think I'm going to stand by
my assessment that this was a lot of effort for a prank that could have been simpler it's never
好吧，我的一个想法是，安迪是那种在第一天就把自己的手机号码给每一个人的那种人。但这并不意味着他们保存了。那是真的。那是真的。但我只是有一种感觉，安迪给吉姆发过短信，比如：我的好兄弟大金枪鱼，想和我一起去喝杯啤酒吗大金枪鱼，你要接电话大金枪鱼，看看我在网上看到的这个疯狂的东西大金枪鱼。好吧，我喜欢这些理论，但我认为我还是要坚持我的评估，即对于一个本可以更简单的恶作剧来说，这付出了太多的努力。这从来都不是
about the prank they just wanted to spend time together you're right right okay let's move on to
Ben Franklin. You guys, big Ben Franklin news. We found Jackie DeBotten, Elizabeth the stripper.
However, her last name is actually pronounced Debiton, Jackie Debiton. But you might remember
she is in this episode. She is also in Fun Run. And then she's going to pop up again in the finale,
spoiler alert. Yes, Jackie reached out to me on DM. I got her cell phone and we've been texting.
she's so sweet and she sent in some audio clips about what it was like working on the show.
Sam, can you play the clip?
Hi, office fans.
关于恶作剧的事，他们只是想花时间在一起。你说得对，对吧。好吧，让我们继续看《本·富兰克林》。伙计们，关于本·富兰克林的重大新闻。我们找到了杰基·德博坦（Jackie DeBotten），伊丽莎白脱衣舞娘。不过，她的姓氏实际上发音为Debiton，杰基·德比顿。但你可能还记得她在这集中。她也在《赛跑》中。然后她会再次出现，在结局中（剧透警告）。是的，杰基在私信中联系了我。我拿到了她的手机号码，我们一直在发短信。她太甜了，她发来了一些音频剪辑，讲述了在剧中工作的感受。山姆，你能播放那个剪辑吗？嗨，办公室的粉丝们。
It's Jackie Debutton, aka Elizabeth, the stripper from the office.
Angela, Jenna, thank you so much for having me on your amazing podcast.
I feel so honored to be here and talk about my memories from this iconic TV show.
One thing I remember so clearly is just how warm and welcoming this entire cast was.
you know, as a guest star actress, sometimes you come on and you feel like you're busting into
somebody's family dinner. But these guys from the second I got there made me feel like part of the
family and so creative and collaborative and nice to me. It was really such a great memory
in that perspective. That is so sweet. I know. Well, in this next clip, she talks about
我是杰基·德比顿，也就是《办公室》里的脱衣舞娘伊丽莎白。安吉拉、詹娜，非常感谢你们邀请我上你们精彩的播客。我感到非常荣幸能来到这里，谈谈我对这部标志性电视剧的记忆。我清楚记得的一件事是，整个演员阵容是多么的温暖和热情。你知道的，作为一个客串女演员，有时你来的时候会觉得自己像是闯入了某个人的家庭晚餐。但这些人从我到达的那一秒起就让我觉得我是他们家庭的一部分，而且非常有创意、合作精神，对我很好。从这个角度来看，这真的是一个非常美好的回忆。太甜了。我知道。好吧，在下一个剪辑中，她谈到了
what it was like working with Steve Correll and also a little bit about what it was like shooting
those dance scenes in the warehouse. Sam, can you play that clip?
He was so sweet and so polite. I would say the day that I had to do the lap dance in the
warehouse, I was not that nervous, but I've also played a lot of strippers in my TV career.
Ironically, I don't know why, because I'm actually an accountant in real life, but that's
probably a different story. We had this amazing costume designer, put together this business
suit that hadn't so much Velcro on it. It was a challenge to get the ripped off at the right
time. We had a couple of wardrobe malfunctions, but we did finally pull it off.
与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作是什么感觉，还有一点关于在仓库里拍摄那些舞蹈场景的感受。山姆，你能播放那个剪辑吗？他太体贴、太礼貌了。我要说的是，我必须在仓库里跳膝上舞的那天，我并不是那么紧张，但在我的电视生涯中，我也演过很多脱衣舞娘。具有讽刺意味的是，我不知道为什么，因为我现实生活中其实是一名会计，但这可能是另一个故事了。我们有这位出色的服装设计师，制作了一套带有大量尼龙搭扣的商务套装。要在正确的时间把它撕下来是一个挑战。我们发生了一些服装故障，但我们最终还是成功了。
Hold up. Jackie is an accountant in real life? Yes. Jackie is an accountant. She's a working
actress and an accountant. Well, I also asked her if she still gets recognized, and here's what she
had to say. I do. I live in New York City now, have for the last eight years.
And, you know, as New York City is, there's always a ton of people in the stores on the street.
And I'll just have someone randomly in the middle of the day or just in the restaurant just come up and go,
oh, my God, you're the stripper from the office, which makes me laugh.
But then, of course, I look around and you can see all these other people looking at me, just random strangers.
And I feel like they might think that I'm like the stripper from like the off.
等等。杰基现实生活中是一名会计？是的。杰基是一名会计。她是一位工作的女演员兼会计。好吧，我还问她是否仍然能被认出来，以下是她的说法。我确实会的。我现在住在纽约市，过去八年一直如此。而且，（你知道的）就像纽约市一样，商店里和街上总是有成吨的人。然后就会有人在白天的某个随机时间或者在餐馆里走过来对我说：“哦，天哪，你就是《办公室》里的那个脱衣舞娘！”这让我大笑。但当然，我环顾四周，你能看到所有其他人在看着我，只是随意的陌生人。我觉得他们可能会认为我就像来自……的脱衣舞娘。
like their office or their office building.
So I feel like I have to explain to them that I, no, it's the shipper from the TV show,
The Office.
But yeah, these fans and these office fans are the most amazing fans.
They're so sweet and they always are asking me tons of questions about what it was like
to be on the show and, you know, what it's like to work with all you amazing, famous people.
And I'm just always so, you know, complimentary of telling them.
how nice everybody was to me.
就像他们的办公室或办公大楼。所以我感觉我必须向他们解释，我，不，这是电视剧《办公室》里的狂热粉丝。但是，是的，这些粉丝和《办公室》的粉丝是最棒的粉丝。他们太贴心了，总是问我很多关于在剧组拍摄是什么感觉，你知道的，和你们所有了不起的名人一起工作是什么感觉。而我总是，你知道的，对大家赞不绝口，告诉他们每个人对我都那么好。
And that I'll always remember this one.
Yeah, I guess that's it, ladies.
I hopefully get to see you all again, wink, wink.
You know, maybe you do that reunion show.
Elizabeth could come back and maybe this time she gets her CPA or something.
All right.
Love you, office fans.
我会永远记住这一幕。好吧，我想就是这样，女士们。希望我能再次见到你们所有人的飞眼。你知道的，也许你们会办个重聚秀。伊丽莎白可以回来，也许这一次她能拿到注册会计师资格或者别的什么。好了。好了。爱你们，《办公室》的粉丝们。
Bye.
Aw, thank you, Jackie.
She was so sweet to send in those clips.
Yes, Jackie, thank you.
And Jackie texted me and she said, my niece is going to be so excited since she is the one to tell me to please check your DMs.
So I just love that, that her niece is bugging her.
So thank you to Jackie's niece for telling her to check her DMs.
So we finally got to connect.
再见。噢，谢谢你，杰琪。她发来这些短片真是太贴心了。是的，杰琪，谢谢你。杰琪发短信告诉我，她的侄女会超级激动，因为是她侄女让我一定要查看私信的。所以我就是喜欢这样，她的侄女一直在缠着她。所以感谢杰琪的侄女让她查看私信。所以我们终于联系上了。
And Jackie said you can find her in a fun indie movie called Crappy Mother's Day.
And she's the lead.
She doesn't know when or where it'll end up.
They just finished it.
But be on the lookout for Crappy Mother's Day.
Happy Mother's Day.
Up next is Phyllis's wedding.
Chris DeLuca had a very interesting theory about who broke wind in Phyllis's dressing room.
杰琪说你可以在一部叫作《糟糕的母亲节》的有趣独立电影里找到她。她是主角。她不知道这部电影何时或会在哪里上映。他们刚刚完成制作。但大家可以留意一下《糟糕的母亲节》。母亲节快乐。接下来是菲莉丝的婚礼。克里斯·德卢卡对谁在菲莉丝的化妆室里放屁有一个非常有趣的理论。
Hmm.
Chris says Phyllis gives a super quick glance right directly at the camera.
Was she trying to blame the camera operator and trying to get them to take the blame?
This is very interesting.
I like this theory.
I do too.
We forgot that there were more people in the room besides just Michael and Phyllis.
Yes. Maybe a member of the documentary crew is the one who tooted. I think so. I love this idea. Chris,
嗯。克里斯说菲莉丝极其迅速地瞥了摄像机一眼。她是不是想把责任推给摄像师，想让他们背锅？这非常有趣。我喜欢这个理论。我也喜欢。我们忘了房间里除了迈克尔和菲莉丝之外还有其他人。是的。也许纪录片摄制组成员才是那个放屁的人。我也这么觉得。我喜欢这个想法。克里斯，
love it. Angela, we spoke a little bit in this episode about that fur handpiece. Lauren Ramirez wrote in to say it is called a muff.
K.K. P.L. Watson went on to say they originally had a small zippered pouch inside where ladies could keep a handkerchief, lipstick, etc.
in place of carrying a purse.
Oh, I would like that.
Well, dare I say, we also needed this because we had no pockets.
Perhaps we had to invent a muff.
Oh, man.
Just give us some pockets and all of our problems will be solved.
太棒了。安吉拉，我们在这一集里简单聊了一下那个皮手筒。劳伦·拉米雷斯写信说这叫作手套筒（muff）。K.K.P.L.沃森接着说，它们原本里面有一个拉链小袋，女士们可以在里面放手帕、口红等，以此来代替带钱包。哦，我想要这个。好吧，我敢说，我们也需要这个，因为我们没有口袋。也许我们得发明一个手套筒。天啊。只要给我们一些口袋，我们所有的烦恼就都解决了。
Give us some dang pockets.
All right.
Jenna, I think we should take a break, but before we do, I have to correct something I got
wrong and revisited.
Okay, this is a revisit of a revisited.
So during our revisited with Dave Rogers, I mentioned I was in a Clay Walker music video.
And Nicole, Erica, Brandy, Hannah, April, and many more.
Let me know I got the lyrics wrong to Clay Walker's song.
给我们一些该死的口袋吧。好了，珍娜，我觉得我们应该休息一下，但在那之前，我必须纠正一些我弄错并重新温习过的事情。好吧，这是对重温内容的再次重温。所以在我们与戴夫·罗杰斯的重温节目中，我提到我曾出演过克レイ·沃克（Clay Walker）的音乐录影带。尼科尔、埃里卡、布兰迪、汉娜、阿普丽尔以及许多其他人。让我知道我把克レイ·沃克歌曲的歌词记错了。
Now, if you know me, you must know, I can never get a song right.
I know like three words of a song and then I'm going to botch it.
It's sort of my superpower.
Like, I will drive you crazy on a road trip because I just always get the lyrics wrong.
So here it is, Clay Walker's song, if I could make a living out of loving you, not I could make a million out of loving you. Sam, can you play the clip?
To be fair, Angela, if he made a million out of loving you, he would also make a living out of loving you. So, right, maybe he could flip it.
You know, he says if he could make a living, he'd make a million.
True. That's how much money he could make, loving you. Well, I went back and watched the music video for this, and I found the moment, the blurry moment where I'm in the video and I'm going to put it in our stories.
现在，如果你了解我，你一定知道，我从来没法把一首歌的歌词唱对。一首歌我大概就知道三个词，然后我就会把它唱得稀巴烂。这可以说是我的超能力。比如，我在公路旅行时会把你逼疯，因为我总是把歌词记错。所以，这就是克レイ·沃克的歌，如果我能靠爱你就谋生（if I could make a living out of loving you），而不是我能靠爱你赚上一百万（I could make a million out of loving you）。山姆，你能放一下那个片段吗？说实话，安吉拉，如果他能靠爱你赚一百万，那他也能靠爱你谋生。所以，对吧，也许他可以把这两句换过来。你知道的，他说如果他能谋生，他就能赚一百万。真的。这就是他靠爱你能赚到多少钱。好吧，我回去看了这首歌的音乐录影带，我找到了那个模糊的瞬间，我在视频里的那个瞬间，我要把它发到我们的快拍里。
Oh my gosh. I love these early acting jobs because this is reminding me of when I was a background extra for the Jurassic Park Ride at Universal Studios.
Ah, what a gig. Amazing. It was a gig. It really was. I got paid $100 to ride.
the Jurassic Park water ride.
By the way, it's a water ride at Universal Studios for 12 hours.
No.
12 hours.
And no.
Yeah.
哦，天哪。我喜欢这些早期的表演工作，因为这让我想起了我在环球影城侏罗纪公园游乐设施当背景演员的时候。啊，真是一份好工作。太棒了。这确实是一份工作。真的。我拿到了一百美元去坐。侏罗纪公园水上游乐设施。顺便说一句，这是环球影城的一个水上游乐设施，持续12个小时。不。12个小时。而且不。对。
Oh, yeah.
You guys, wait, I have to put some context in this.
I have done this ride.
It has got such a huge drop.
Yep.
I've done it with the kids.
We bought the photo, you know, the photo when you do the drop.
And the kids' faces, it's like horror.
哦，是的。你们，等等，我得为这事加点背景。我坐过这个游乐设施。它有一个超级大的俯冲落差。是的。我和孩子们一起坐过。我们买过那张照片，你知道的，就是俯冲时拍的那张照片。孩子们的脸上，简直是一副惊恐的表情。
The drop is so much bigger than you can prepare for.
and I got completely soaked.
I had to go to the gift shop and I had to buy a pair of sweatpants to wear around the rest of the day because I was drenched.
Yeah.
This was my first acting job when I arrived in Los Angeles.
My friend and I both signed up.
Oh, my God.
We were so excited when we got to Universal Studios.
那个落差比你能心理准备的要大得多。而且我全身湿透了。我不得不去礼品店买了一条运动裤，在接下来的时间里穿着，因为我湿透了。是的。这是我刚到洛杉矶时的第一份表演工作。我和朋友都报名了。天啊。当我们到达环球影城时，我们兴奋极了。
As we're walking in, we passed by Arnold Schwarzenegger shooting baskets outside of a soundstage.
We were like, we have arrived.
This is going to be the best day ever.
Woo-hoo! Twelve hours later. Did you cry at you left?
The difference of us walking to the gig and walking from the gig at the end of the day, we were so beaten down.
I want to say at a certain point, they felt like they weren't getting on camera enough water splashing on us to indicate that it was a water ride.
No.
So the first thing they did was they had guys with buckets of water that they would just throw on us as we scooted by in the little boat.
当我们走进去的时候，我们经过了阿诺德·施瓦辛格在声音舞台外面投篮的地方。我们当时想，我们到了。这将是有史以来最好的一天。呜呼！十二个小时后。你离开时哭了吗？我们走向工作地点和在一天结束时离开工作地点的状态完全不同，我们累得精疲力竭。我想说，在某个时候，他们觉得水花溅在我们身上还不够多，不足以表明这是一个水上游乐设施。不。所以他们做的第一件事就是找来几个拿着水桶的家伙，当我们坐着小船从旁边滑过时，就把水直接泼在我们身上。
Oh, no.
But at one point, not even that was enough.
They got out what's called a water cannon.
No.
Yep.
Oh, my gosh.
They shoot cannon balls of water at you.
Can you?
哦，不。但到了后来，甚至这都还不够。他们拿出了所谓的“水炮”。不。是的。哦，天哪。他们向你发射水炮球。你能吗？
I can't believe I didn't just drive back to Missouri after that.
This is being an actor.
Yeah.
12 hours.
I wrote that ride one time and I was like, I'm never doing it again.
Well, if you see the commercial, there is a spot.
where you can pause. And for one second, half of me is on screen. So lady, while you were dancing to this
Claywalker music video, I was getting hit by a water cannon. That's showbis folks. Oh, man. Well, let's take a
我简直不敢相信自己在经历那一切之后竟然没有直接开车回密苏里州。这就是当演员。是的。12个小时。我坐过那次游乐设施一次，当时我就想，我再也不坐了。好吧，如果你看广告，有一个地方。你可以暂停。而且有一秒钟，我的一半身体在屏幕上。所以女士，当你随着这个克レイ·沃克的音乐录影带跳舞时，我正被水炮击中。这就是娱乐圈，伙计们。哦，天哪。好吧，我们休息一下，
break and we will come back and we'll start with business school. All right. We are back. We're going to
start with business school. This is the episode with Pam's art show. And we got mail lady from so many artists.
after this episode because they really connected with Pam.
This is also the episode with the bat in the office and several people shared with us
about having bats in their offices.
What?
Bats in their offices?
Yes, listen to this one.
然后回来，从《商业学校》开始。好的。我们回来了。我们要从《商业学校》开始。这一集是关于潘的艺术展的。这一集之后，我们收到了来自许多艺术家的邮件，因为他们真的与潘产生了共鸣。这一集里办公室里还有一只蝙蝠，好几个人跟我们分享了他们办公室里也有过蝙蝠的经历。什么？他们的办公室里有蝙蝠？是的，听听这个。
Kelly Rarden said, rewatching this episode gave me flashbacks of the time I was working
alone in my office late at night during a thunderstorm and a bat started swooping at my head.
I was on a tight deadline, so I had to dodge the bat for an hour while I tried to continue working.
Kelly, did you get a rabies shot?
I hope Kelly got a rabies shot, remember?
You can't always feel it when they bite you.
I know, they're sneaky.
And speaking of bats, Kendra Zane said,
凯莉·拉登说，重看这一集让我想起了雷雨交加的深夜，我一个人在办公室加班，一只蝙蝠开始朝我的头俯冲的经历。我当时手头有个紧迫的截止日期，所以我不得不一边躲避蝙蝠一个小时，一边试图继续工作。凯莉，你打了狂犬病疫苗吗？我希望凯莉打了狂犬病疫苗，记得吗？它们咬你的时候你并不一定能感觉到。我知道，它们太鬼祟了。说到蝙蝠，肯德拉·赞恩说，
I can't believe you guys didn't touch on the rabies foreshadowing with Meredith.
Kendra, we totally should have.
Great catch.
All right, Angela, remember cocktails?
Yes, I do.
Michael goes to the party at David Wallace's house.
Do you remember the creepy ghost lady in the background of Michael's talking head?
How could I forget?
真不敢相信你们竟然没有提到梅雷迪思身上关于狂犬病的伏笔。肯德拉，我们绝对应该提到的。抓得好。好的，安吉拉，还记得鸡尾酒会吗？是的，我记得。迈克尔去了戴维·华莱士家的派对。你还记得迈克尔面对镜头独白时背景里那个诡异的女鬼吗？我怎么会忘呢？
So creepy.
A lot of people wrote in to say they think it was someone from the catering staff.
Wow.
They noted that the woman is wearing the same burgundy top as the other caterers.
And they think she's chopping something or maybe washing dishes because her shoulders and arms are kind of moving a little bit.
You guys really, really gave this a once over.
I mean, if you're clocking her shoulder movements, I'm impressed.
Well, Mando said the ghost from the talking head is also in the kitchen at six minutes 33 seconds as David's wife puts down Michael's potato salad.
太诡异了。很多人写信来说，他们觉得那是餐饮服务人员。哇。他们指出，那个女人穿着和其他餐饮人员相同的勃艮第红上衣。他们觉得她在切东西或者可能在洗盘子，因为她的肩膀和手臂在稍微动一动。你们真的把这一幕仔仔细细看了一遍。我是说，如果你连她肩膀的动作品都注意到了，我真的很佩服。好吧，曼多说，独白镜头里的那个鬼魂在第6分33秒时也在厨房里，当时戴维的妻子放下了迈克尔的土豆沙拉。
And Leslie Heath said, you can see her walk behind Michael and Jan at 14 minutes, three seconds.
This is so much more than I ever thought we would know about this ghost woman.
I know, it's so true.
So not a ghost member of catering staff.
Okay.
I've got a few more catches for you.
Charlie said,
I'd like to point out that when Jan presents Michael with their love contract,
莱斯利·希思说，你可以在第14分3秒时看到她走在迈克尔和简的身后。这比我们以为自己会知道的关于这个女鬼的信息要多得多。我知道，确实如此。所以不是鬼魂，是餐饮服务人员。好的。我还有几个细节要跟你们分享。查理说，我想指出的是，当简向迈克尔出示他们的恋爱合同时，
Michael says,
I'm going to frame mine.
In the later episode,
The Deposition,
when Jan is attempting to sue Dunder Mifflin,
Michael presents the contract as evidence and it's in a black frame.
Nice.
It's so good, isn't it?
迈克尔说：“我要把它装裱起来。”在后来的剧集《听证会》中，当简试图起诉邓德米夫林时，迈克尔将合同作为证据出示，而且它装在一个黑色的相框里。太棒了。真的很棒，对吧？
And Chris G says,
you didn't mention the fact that Jan drove her own car to the party,
but then rode home with Michael.
What happened to her car?
I had wondered about that.
I have to say,
I wondered,
did they have to drive back to David Wallace's house and pick up her car?
克里斯·G说，你们没有提到简自己开车去派对，但后来却是坐迈克尔的车回家的事实。她的车怎么了？我之前还纳闷过这事。我得说，我想知道，他们是不是还得开车回戴维·华莱士家去把她的车开回来？
You know what I think she did.
I think she sent Michael in a cab the next day to get her car.
I think she drank too much wine.
Oh, well,
that's for sure why Michael drove her.
But how she retrieved her car,
I bet she made Michael go get it.
And then I bet Michael made Dwight go get it.
你知道我觉得她是怎么做的吗？我觉得她第二天派迈克尔坐出租车去把她的车开回来了。我觉得她酒喝多了。哦，好吧，迈克尔开车送她绝对是因为这个。但至于她是怎么取回车的，我敢打赌她让迈克尔去取了。然后我敢打赌迈克尔让德怀特去取了。
Exactly.
Well, moving on to the negotiation, my pockets soapbox got a lot of mail.
In support of my position, one of my favorites came from Melanie Vergara, who said,
ladies, I feel so strongly about the symbology of pockets that I refuse to even consider
buying a wedding dress without pockets.
And I found the wedding dress of my dreams.
It has pockets.
没错。没错。好吧，说到谈判，关于我口袋的言论收到了很多邮件。为了支持我的立场，我最喜欢的邮件之一来自梅兰妮·维加拉，她说：“女士们，我对口袋的象征意义深信不疑，以至于我甚至拒绝考虑购买没有口袋的婚纱。我找到了我梦寐以求的婚纱。它有口袋。”
She's going to wear it this year.
I mean, a wedding dress with pockets is pretty phenomenal.
Yeah.
Well, Kenny, who is a historian, wrote in and had a correction for us.
Kenny says women had pockets throughout history until the 1800s,
when for various complicated and mostly sexist reasons, women lost their pockets.
So yes, the lack of pockets is a sexist thing, but the 400 years ago thing is wrong.
It's more like 200.
她今年就要穿这件婚纱了。我是说，带口袋的婚纱相当了不起。是的。好吧，身为历史学家的肯尼写信给我们，并纠正了我们一个错误。肯尼说，女性在历史上一直都有口袋，直到19世纪，由于各种复杂且主要是性别歧视的原因，女性失去了口袋。所以是的，没有口袋是一件带有性别歧视的事情，但“400年前”这种说法是错的。大概是200年前。
Secondly, she says, corsets were not bad for you.
In fact, they gave you great back support.
The reason corsets hurt people today is because they either haven't broken them in,
the same way you have to break in a stiff material shoe before they're comfortable,
or because they are not fitted properly because people today don't realize the absolute importance of a well-fitted corset
and that she would personally take a corset over a bra any day.
Wow.
It's a lot of information there.
其次，她说，束腰胸衣对你并没有坏处。事实上，它们能给你的背部提供极好的支撑。如今束腰胸衣之所以会弄痛人，是因为人们要么没有把它们穿软，就像你必须把一双硬质材料的鞋子穿软才能觉得舒服一样，要么是因为它们尺码不合适，因为如今的人们没有意识到合身的束腰胸衣的绝对重要性，而且她个人宁愿穿束腰胸衣也绝不穿文胸。哇。那里有很多信息。
Kinney?
I could not love this letter more.
Thank you very much.
Although I do have to say, having worn many corsets for acting projects over the year,
perhaps they were ill-fitted, I'm going to go ahead and take a bra.
You're going to take a bra over a corset?
I'm going to take a sports bra if I'm being honest.
I don't even want any of the underwire if I can avoid it.
肯尼？我再怎么喜欢这封信也不为过了。非常感谢。虽然我不得不说，多年来因为演艺项目穿过很多束腰胸衣后，也许它们当时就不合身，但我还是会选择文胸。你宁愿选文胸也不选束腰胸衣？说实话，我会选运动文胸。如果可以避免的话，我甚至连钢圈都不想要。
You're going to go uniboub and be fine with it.
Here's the thing.
When I get dressed in the mornings, I like to get dressed.
as if I might have to break into a full sprint at some point in the day.
Okay?
Your panic button is ready.
If you need to run, if you need to haul ass.
Yeah, I'm dressed for it.
你会选择单乳（uniboub），然后觉得这样挺好。事情是这样的。我早上穿衣服时，我喜欢穿成。随时准备在一天中的某个时刻冲刺的样子。好吗？你的求生按钮已经准备好了。如果你需要跑，如果你需要拼命赶路。是的，我都为此穿好了衣服。
If there's an apocalyptic event, I'm ready.
Men are naturally dressed this way.
Truly, a man could pretty much break into a sprint pretty easily, right?
Well, I want to survive end of times, a possible mugging.
I don't know.
So no corsets, no spanks.
No high heels for me. I need to run to my bag of expired medication, my book bag with my protein bars,
my backpack with the solar panel so I can charge my phone. It's full. You know what I have in my
如果有末日事件发生，我已经准备好了。男人们天生就是这样穿衣服的。真的，一个男人基本上可以非常轻松地开始冲刺，对吧？好吧，我想在末日劫难、可能的抢劫中存活下来。我不知道。所以不要束腰胸衣，不要紧身衣。我不要高跟鞋。我需要跑到我的过期药品包里，背着装有能量棒的书包，背着带有太阳能电池板以便给手机充电的双肩包。它已经满了。你知道我的里有什么吗？
emergency backpack, Angela? We live in Southern California, but I have four of those foil blankets
that you wrap around yourself, like for extreme cold temperature, because you don't know. You don't know
the weather shift that's going to happen if a meteor hits the earth.
This is like that Jake Gyllenhaal movie the day after tomorrow where, you know, all of a
sudden this like crazy Arctic storm freezes all of New York City.
Right.
I would have a foil blanket for that.
And I would have comfortable clothing with giant pockets.
应急双肩包，安吉拉？我们住在南加州，但我有四条那种可以裹在身上的箔毯，就像是为了极端寒冷的天气准备的，因为你不知道。你不知道如果一颗陨石撞击地球，天气会发生怎样的变化。这就像杰克·吉伦哈尔主演的那部电影《后天》，你知道的，突然之间这种疯狂的北极风暴冻结了纽约市的所有地方。没错。我会为此准备一张箔毯。我会穿着带有巨大口袋的舒适衣服。
I would be as ready as possible.
You see what I'm saying?
I can't wear a corset.
I do.
No, you can't.
You can't wear a corset.
Jenna, you know, my theory on all of this is like what they say about a bear.
attack. You only have to run faster than one other person. Oh my God. I only have to be faster than one
我会尽可能做好准备。你明白我的意思吗？我不能穿束腰胸衣。我明白。不，你不能。你不能穿束腰胸衣。珍娜，你知道我对此的所有理论就像人们对熊的攻击的看法一样。你只需要跑得比另一个人快就行了。天啊。我只需要比群体中的另一个
other person in the pack and I'll be okay. It's so interesting they didn't use that quote in the
edge. They went with what one man has done another can do, but yours is also very inspiring.
Okay. Well, Jenna, it was also during the negotiation that we discussed our love of Keanu Reeves movies.
And last week we found out that you have not been watching John Wick.
I'm so sorry.
Well, I guess there are a few Keanu Reeves slash the office crossover connections.
What?
We are like six degrees separation of Keanu Reeves.
人跑得快，我就能没事了。真有趣，他们在片中没有使用那句名言。他们用的是“人能做到的事，别人也能做到”，但你的也很有启发性。好吧。好吧，珍娜，也是在谈判期间，我们讨论了我们对基努·里维斯电影的热爱。上周我们发现你一直没有看《疾速追杀》（John Wick）。我很抱歉。好吧，我想基努·里维斯和《办公室》之间有一些交叉联系。什么？我们和基努·里维斯只有六度分隔。
We almost know him.
What?
Ready?
Wait, I could blow your mind right now.
What?
Have you met him?
Jenna Fisher, have you met Keanu Reeves?
No.
我们几乎认识他。什么？准备好了吗？等等，我现在可能会让你脑洞大开。什么？你见过他吗？珍娜·菲舍尔，你见过基努·里维斯吗？没有。
but I was at a birthday party with him for a mutual friend.
But I never got up the courage to cross the room and introduce myself.
And this happened like recently.
Like before coronavirus.
I have no words.
Did I forget to tell you that?
What is wrong with you?
How could you forget to tell me this?
但我曾和一个共同的朋友一起参加过他的生日派对。但我从来没有鼓起勇气穿过房间去作自我介绍。这发生得就像最近一样。就像在冠状病毒爆发之前。我无话可说。我忘告诉你了吗？你怎么了？你怎么能忘了告诉我这件事？
We have talked for six months about Keanu Reeves.
I know.
And you know, it's really weird because when you told me I had a Keanu Reeves office connection,
I got really excited because I think I'd forgotten that I had actually.
actually been in the same room with him once. Well, I have one Keanu Reeve story. I guess I haven't
shared it with you. I don't know why we don't share with each other about our Keanu Reeve stories.
What's happened to us? We used to be best friends. What's going on? In my early 20s, I was performing
improv at IOW West in Hollywood and I was at a red light crossing the street to go to the theater
我们已经讨论了六个月的基努·里维斯了。我知道。你知道的，这真的很奇怪，因为当你告诉我我和《办公室》里的基努·里维斯有联系时，我真的很兴奋，因为我想我忘记了其实我。其实曾经和他待在同一个房间里过。好吧，我有一个基努·里维斯的故事。我想我没有跟你分享过。我不知道为什么我们不跟对方分享我们的基努·里维斯故事。我们怎么了？我们过去是最好的朋友。怎么回事？在我20多岁的时候，我在好莱坞的IOW West表演即兴喜剧，当时我正准备过马路去剧院，
with Wyatt Sannack. Some of you guys might know Wyatt. He is very funny, talented comedian performer.
We were standing on the street corner and like a SUV pulled up.
And in the passenger seat was Keanu Reeves.
And I was prime Kinsey Twinnies.
Tanked up, little shorts.
Uh-huh.
Right.
And Wyatt Snack goes, oh, my God, it's Keanu Reeves.
和怀亚特·桑纳克（Wyatt Sannack）一起在一个红灯路口。你们有些人可能认识怀亚特。他是一个非常有趣、极具天赋的喜剧演员。我们正站在街角，然后一辆SUV停了下来。坐在副驾驶座上的是基努·里维斯。而我当时正处于金西双性恋（Kinsey Twinnies）的巅峰期。穿着吊带背心，短裤。嗯哼。没错。然后怀亚特·桑纳克说：“哦，天哪，那是基努·里维斯。”
And I was like, huh?
And he goes, he just checked you out.
Kinsey, he just checked you out.
I was like, no.
Wyatt, if you are making this up, you better not be messing with me.
And then the car pulled away.
But he was like, no.
Ange, Keanu Reeves looks you up and down.
然后我说，啊？他说，他刚刚打量了你。金西，他刚刚打量了你。我说，才没有。怀亚特，如果你是在瞎编，你最好别拿我开玩笑道。然后车开走了。但他还是说，真的。安吉，基努·里维斯把你从头到脚看了一遍。
I was like, no!
I don't know if this is true.
No, you make that true.
You make that true.
It's now part of my personal history.
It's your personal history and you can hold that forever.
Wyatt, thank you.
All right, well, what are the Keanu Reeves office connections?
我说，不会吧！我不知道这是不是真的。不，你得把它变成真的。你得把它变成真的。这现在是我个人历史的一部分了。这是你的个人历史，你可以永远把它记在心里。怀亚特，谢谢你。好吧，那么，基努·里维斯和办公室有什么联系呢？
Oh, yes.
Because I want to know.
Here are our crossover connections.
Ali Lincoln said, I have a correction.
Speed is fantastic.
But peak, Keanu Reeves hotness
includes David Denman in the replacements.
If you don't get the chills when David is Brian scores a touchdown, you're broken.
哦，是的。因为我想知道。以下是我们的交叉联系。阿莉·林肯说，我有个修正。生死时速太棒了。但基努·里维斯的颜值巅峰包括替补队员里的大卫·丹曼。如果大卫饰演的布莱恩得分时你没有起鸡皮疙瘩，那你肯定出毛病了。
Wait.
So David Denman knows Keanu Reeves.
Why didn't we talk to David about Keanu Reeves?
Why haven't we been exploiting this relationship?
Exactly.
Okay.
And a great catch by Drew Knox.
They say the movie Speed features the amazing Beth Grant, who later appears in a couple of episodes
等等。所以大卫·丹曼认识基努·里维斯。我们为什么不找大卫聊聊基努·里维斯呢？我们为什么没有好好利用这种关系呢？没错。好的，德鲁·诺克斯有一个很好的发现。他们说电影《生死时速》里有极棒的贝丝·格兰特，她后来出现在好几集里。
with you all, most notably in the dinner party.
as Dwight's date slash ex-babysitter Melvina.
Yes.
Applaws.
That is fantastic.
She is the woman who's very, very nervous about getting off the bus and walking across
the little plank.
和你们一起，最显著的是在晚宴那一集。饰演德 Dwight 的约会对象兼前保姆梅尔维娜。对。对。掌声。太棒了。她就是那个对于下车并走过那个小木板感到非常非常紧张的女人。
Yes.
To the other speeding vehicle with the police.
Oh, my gosh.
That is just really good Keanu office crossover.
I'm moving us along to safety training.
Angela, you told the story about how your mom gets people's names.
wrong. Yes. You gave an example of how your mom would call your friend Bart Mart. She called
them Mart. We asked who would ever name their kid Mart. I think you asked that. I did.
是的。走向警察开着的另一辆超速行驶的车。哦，天哪。这真的是很棒的基努与办公室的交叉点。我把话题转到安全培训。安吉拉，你讲过一个关于你妈妈总是记错别人名字的故事。是的。你举了一个例子，说你妈妈会把你的朋友巴特叫作马特。她管他们叫马特。我们当时问谁会给自己的孩子起名叫马特。我想是你问的。我问的。
I did ask that. Let me just throwing you under the bus. Well, it's fine because after we recorded
that day, I was curious and I googled it. And apparently a lot of people in Estonia name their
children, Mart, and two of Estonia's prime ministers have been named Mart. Mart, Silliman, and
Mart Lar. Mart Lar. He is a prime minister, former prime minister of Estonia. There you go.
We also wondered, and Angela, we both wondered, why Andy brought his lunch to work on a plate covered in foil.
Yes. Many people, including Lee Miller, Shaley Taylor, Hannah Ermie, and Megan Bennett said,
it was the plate of cookies that Andy brought to share with everyone.
It was a deleted scene.
确实是我问的。我就当是在拆自己的台吧。好吧，没关系，因为那天录完音后，我很感激，于是我谷歌了一下。显然爱沙尼亚有很多人给孩子起名叫马特，而且爱沙尼亚有两位首相都叫马特。马特·拉尔。马特·拉尔。他是爱沙尼亚的首相，前首相。你看。我们还纳闷，安吉拉，我们俩都纳闷，为什么安迪要把午饭用盘子装着，上面还盖着锡纸带到公司来。是的。很多人，包括莉·米勒、谢利·泰勒、汉娜·厄米和梅根·贝内特都说，那是安迪带了跟大家分享的一盘曲奇饼干。那是一段被删减的镜头。
Yes, it was.
You're so right.
I should have caught that.
Prison Mike added the people who brought their lunch to work on a plate covered in foil were Roy and Pam.
Remember when they were eating their way through all of their unused reception meals?
Oh, that is right.
Yes, I remember that storyline now.
All right.
对，确实是的。你太对了。我本该想到的。监狱迈克补充说，那些用盘子装午饭并盖上锡纸带到公司的人是罗伊和帕姆。还记得他们当时正吃光所有他们没用过的接待餐吗？哦，对的。是的，我现在记起那个情节了。好吧。
We have more to cover.
And next up is women's appreciation.
Oh, gosh.
had some interesting mail on this one.
Yes, you might remember that in women's appreciation,
Phyllis gets flashed in the parking lot.
And this leads Dwight to setting up a hotline to find the predator.
And he holds up a flyer in the episode and it has a phone number very clearly printed on it.
我们还有更多内容要讲。接下来是女性赞赏日。哦，天哪。关于这一集，我们收到了一些有趣的信件。是的，你可能还记得在女性赞赏日那一集里，菲利斯在停车场被人当众暴露狂性骚扰了。这导致德怀特设立了一条热线来寻找那个变态。他在剧中举起了一张传单上面非常清晰地印着一个电话号码。
And when the episode aired,
we shared that if you called that number,
you heard a voicemail from Dwight.
Well, apparently the phone number on that flyer is now
wait for it, a sex hotline.
Yes.
So I am filing this under, I don't know, what should I file it under?
OMG.
当这一集播出时，我们分享说如果你拨打那个号码，你会听到一段德怀特留下的语音信箱。好吧，显然那张传单上的电话号码现在——大家准备好了吗——变成了一条色情热线。是的。所以我把这个归类为，我不知道，我该把它归类为什么？天哪。
Sarah wrote in and said, I called the hotline number from this week's episode.
It is a sex call line.
Oh, the irony.
Guess it's no longer to report flashing now.
Jenna.
What?
I called the number two.
You did not.
莎拉写信说，我打了本周这一集里的热线号码。那是一条色情电话热线。哦，太讽刺了。看来现在已经不是用来举报暴露狂的时候了。珍娜。什么？我也打了那个号码。你才没有。
I did.
I had to know.
Okay.
It's the 800 number on the flyer that's on the first.
Crop, right?
Yes.
So, Sam, I want you to call this number.
我打了。我得知道。我必须知道。好吧。就是传单上的那个800开头的号码，对吧？对。所以，萨姆，我想让你打这个号码。
Welcome to America's hottest talk line.
Guys, hot ladies are waiting to talk to you.
Press one now.
Okay, hang up.
Okay.
Wow.
Guys, welcome to the hottest text line.
欢迎来到美国最火爆的聊天热线。伙计们，火辣的美女们正等着和你们聊天呢。现在请按一。好吧，挂断。好吧。好吧。哇。伙计们，欢迎来到最火爆的短信热线。
Let me ask you a question.
Yeah.
That voice is often used when women are being flirtatious and coy.
Men, do you like that voice?
Does that voice turn you on?
Hi.
What is up?
right now. What is up right now is what I want to know. Are you up right now? I mean, is that
我问你个问题。行。这种声音通常是女性表现得调情和害羞时使用的。男士们，你们喜欢这种声音吗？这种声音会让你们有感觉吗？嗨。怎么回事？现在到底怎么回事。我现在想知道的是到底怎么回事。你现在醒着吗？我是说，这难道是
getting you there? That voice gets you there. Sorry, lady on sex hotline, but I feel like she's
putting on like sexy voice. Uh-uh. I think that's how she talks in real life. I think when she goes to
the grocery store, she's like, what is your price on avocados this week? Well, I hope she's not
talking to the grocery store workers about that because they're all going to get so turned on.
Okay, and a lot of people wished we had discussed a certain scene in the food court where Pam and Karen have very different opinions on Michael's relationship with Jan.
Sarah Gray, MC, Michelle G., Nicole Clem, Armanda, Yassena P., Emily Lucille, and Alexis Leary, and many more all said when Karen says sometimes you just have to push through rough patches.
and Pam says maybe it sounds like you two are just wrong for each other.
And then they share an awkward look.
让你有感觉了吗？那种声音能让你有感觉。对不起，色情热线上的女士，但我觉得她是在故意装出性感的声音。才不。我觉得她现实生活中就是这么说话的。我觉得她去杂货店时会说，你们这周的牛油果是什么价钱？好吧，我希望她不要跟杂货店的员工谈论这个，因为他们都会很有感觉的。好的，很多人希望我们讨论美食广场里的某个场景，在那里帕姆和卡伦对迈克尔与简的关系有着截然不同的看法。莎拉·格雷、MC、米歇尔·G、妮可·克莱姆、阿尔曼达、雅森娜·P、艾米丽·露辛尔、亚历西斯·利里以及更多人纷纷表示，当卡伦说有时你只需咬牙挺过艰难时期。
I really wanted to hear you guys break that down.
All right, this is a missed opportunity because I do have thoughts.
Well, I'm sure you probably did.
Here's what I find interesting.
I think it's really interesting that their advice to Michael seems to be kind of the opposite
of how we've seen them in their own relationships.
I feel like Pam was always pushing through rough patches, you know, and Karen always felt to me like
the example of a more kind of assertive empowered women who would say, listen, maybe this just isn't a
而帕姆说也许这听起来你们两个根本就不适合对方。然后他们交换了一个尴尬的眼神。我真的很想听听你们剖析一下。好吧，这是一个错失的机会，因为我确实有想法。好吧，我相信你肯定有。我觉得有趣的是。我觉得很有趣的是，她们给迈克尔的建议似乎跟我们看到的她们自己在感情中的表现正好相反。我觉得帕姆总是咬牙挺过艰难时期，你知道的，而卡伦在我看来一直是那种更有主见、更有力量的女性的代表，她会说，听着，也许这根本就不是个。
match.
So I found it interesting that their advice to Michael was a little different than how maybe they
live their own lives.
Yeah, I mean, they're both just speaking where they're at.
That's what I thought.
Well, it's true.
I think Karen has been in a giant rough patch with.
Jim from the beginning that she keeps trying to convince herself that this is a great relationship
般配。所以我发现她们给迈克尔的建议和她们自己实际生活中的方式有点不太一样。对，我是说，她们只是在说各自的现状。我是这么想的。好吧，确实如此。我觉得卡伦从一开始就和吉姆经历了一段非常艰难的时期，她一直在试图说服自己这是一段很棒的感情。
for her. So I think there's some truth in that. Yeah. And Pam is finally done doing that.
You're right. She's living a more authentic life. She can be more honest with herself. And so she's
more honest with others. Yeah. I hear that too. In the same episode, Karina and Maggie wrote in and
said they were sad that we did not discuss Angela's large colonial dolls talking head. I was too, Jenna.
I was bummed. After the fact, I was like, oh my gosh, that's like one of my favorite talking heads.
And I can't believe I didn't talk about it.
I think we just had so much to cover in this episode that we didn't get to everything.
I agree.
对她来说。所以我觉得这里面有些道理。是的。而帕姆终于不再那样做了。你说得对。她过着更真实的生活。她能对自己更诚实，所以她对别人也更诚实。是的。我也这么觉得。在同一集里，卡琳娜和玛吉来信说，她们很难过我们没有讨论安吉拉关于大型殖民地娃娃的访谈镜头。我也是，珍娜。我很沮丧。事后我想，哦，天哪，那简直是我最喜欢的访谈镜头之一。我简直不敢相信我没聊到它。我想我们这一集要聊的内容实在太多了，以至于没能覆盖到所有内容。我同意。
But this is for Karina and Maggie.
Sometimes the clothes at Gap Kids are just too flashy.
So I'm forced to go to the American Girl Store and order clothes for large colonial dolls.
I'll have you know.
There is no way you could fit into that doll clothing.
I mean, you are tiny.
Yes.
But I feel like I could put that clothing on my cat.
但这是给卡琳娜和玛吉的。有时候Gap Kids的衣服实在是太花哨了。所以我被迫去美国女孩商店为大型殖民地娃娃订购衣服。我得告诉你们。你绝对穿不下那套娃娃的衣服。我是说，你太娇小了。是的。但我觉得我可以把那套衣服穿在我的猫身上。
It's very tiny.
I know.
It's so ridiculous.
Oh.
Oh, and I have to point out one thing on a personal note.
This is one of the only episodes that I actually wore panty hose in.
I knew I would be cold at this mall.
Jenna, this was our mall.
它太小了。我知道。太荒谬了。哦。哦，我得从个人角度指出一件事。这是我唯一真正穿过连裤袜的剧集之一。我知道我在这个商场里会觉得冷。珍娜，这是我们的商场。
We know this mall.
I always freeze.
It's cold.
And I decided to wear panty hose.
You can see them when I'm seated talking to Michael in Victoria's Secrets.
Yes.
Meanwhile, I've had panty hose on for three years because I didn't know that you could just refuse to wear them.
All right.
我们了解这个商场。我总是冻得够呛。里面很冷。我决定穿连裤袜。当我在维多利亚的秘密坐着跟迈克尔说话时，你能看到它们。是的。与此同时，我已经穿了三年连裤袜了，因为我不知道你可以直接拒绝穿它们。好吧。
Moving into Beach Games, this was a very big episode and we really did try to cover everything.
Again, we missed a few things.
We got some mail about the scene where the group arrives at Lakes Granton.
So the bus has just parked.
Everyone's filing off the bus.
Fan question from Alyssa Jessel, Joel M. and Jen Seeley.
As Michael gets off the bus,
He says, watch out for snakes.
进入沙滩游戏，这是非常重要的一集，我们确实试图涵盖所有内容。再次声明，我们漏掉了一些。我们收到了一些关于大家到达格兰顿湖的场景的邮件。所以巴士刚刚停下。每个人都在排队下车。来自阿丽莎·杰塞尔、乔尔·M和珍·西利的粉丝提问。当迈克尔下车时，他说，当心蛇。
And he kind of mugs for the camera.
Well, this line actually comes from the movie EGA.
Let me spell that for you.
It's E-E-G-A-H.
This movie was featured on Mystery Science Theater 3000, and that line has become a running joke.
So these guys want to know, was the line written or improvised?
Do we think that Michael liked the movie E-GAS?
Or do we think maybe Michael is a fan of mystery science theater 3,000?
而且他有点对着镜头搞怪。好吧，这句台词实际上出自电影EGA。我来给你拼一下。它是E-E-G-A-H。这部电影曾在《神秘科学剧场3000》中亮相，那句台词成了一个老梗。所以这些人想知道，这句台词是剧本写的还是即兴发挥的？我们觉得迈克尔喜欢电影《EGA》吗？还是我们觉得迈克尔可能是《神秘科学剧场3000》的粉丝？
Guys, we asked Jen Salata, writer of this episode, and she said this was 100% a coincidence.
It was not intentional.
When Michael says, watch out for snakes getting off the bus, that line was written because
she just thought it would be really funny if the first thing Michael says to us as we arrive
at the beach is something that would make the beach completely not fun, which would be snakes.
Right.
She also said that, I guess, there was a real warning to watch out for snakes.
The cast and crew.
伙计们，我们问了这一集的编剧珍·萨拉塔，她说这100%是个巧合。这不是故意的。当迈克尔下车时说“当心蛇”时，这句台词之所以被写出来，是因为她觉得如果迈克尔刚到达海滩对我们说的第一句话是一件会让海滩变得一点也不好玩的事情，那会非常搞笑，那就是蛇。没错。她还说，我想，当时确实有一个要当心蛇的真实警告。演员和剧组人员。
Yes.
I wanted to take a second and mention one of my favorite deleted Phyllis talking heads from this episode.
They're all talking about if Jim would be a good boss or not, right?
Yes.
Because he's up for this job at corporate, right?
That's right.
He's up for the job.
And Phyllis says, in a talking head to camera, I think Jim would be a good boss.
是的。我想花点时间提一下这集中我最喜欢的被删减的菲利斯的访谈镜头之一。大家都在讨论吉姆会不会是个好老板，对吧？是的。因为他在竞争公司总部的那个职位，对吧？没错。他在竞争那个职位。而菲利斯在对镜头的访谈中说，我觉得吉姆会是个好老板。
Plus, he's eye candy.
It's okay.
Bob Vance knows he's on my list.
George Clooney, Leo DiCaprio.
Jim and that British guy who got in trouble with the prostitute.
I guess that would be Hugh Grant.
Wow.
And Bob knows.
另外，他很养眼。没关系。鲍勃·万斯知道他在我的名单上。乔治·克鲁尼，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。吉姆，还有那个惹上妓女麻烦的英国佬。我想那是休·格兰特吧。哇。鲍勃知道了。
Bob knows and he's okay with it.
Okay.
So Meredith hits on Jim to sign her cast.
Phyllis has Jim on her list.
Yeah.
Wow.
Phyllis.
The ladies are going after your fella.
鲍勃知道了，而且他觉得没关系。好吧。所以梅雷迪思勾引吉姆让她在石膏上签名。菲利斯把吉姆列入了她的名单。对。哇。菲利斯。女士们都在追你的男人呢。
More fan mail lady from Krista Kay.
She says,
I believe it was Jenna that equated walking
over lava stones to walking on Lego bricks. I wanted you guys to know that doing a Lego walk,
which is walking endlessly on Lego bricks, is actually a thing that happens during Lego fan conventions.
Krista said she tried it once and failed miserably, but her husband did all right one year.
And during last year's Philly Brick Fest, the Guinness World Record was set at 2,737 feet. But listen to this.
That record was shattered on November 20th, 2020 by someone named LA Beast, who took a video of themselves walking 12,750 feet over a bunch of Lego.
来自克丽斯塔·K的更多粉丝来信。她说，我相信是珍娜把走过火山石比作走在乐高积木上。我想让你们知道，进行“乐高步行”，也就是在乐高积木上无休止地行走，实际上是乐高粉丝大会期间会发生的一件事情。克丽斯塔说她曾经尝试过一次并且惨败，但她丈夫有一年表现得还不错。在去年的费城乐高节上，吉尼斯世界纪录被定格在2737英尺。但听好了。这个纪录在2020年11月20日被一个叫LA Beast的人打破了，他拍下了自己在一堆乐高积木上走过12750英尺的视频。
And there's a video on YouTube, but she said it's like an hour long.
That is crazy.
Someone walked on Legos for an hour.
All I could think of as a parent was, oh my God, who had to pick up all those stinking Legos when it was done?
Yeah.
That's a lot of Lego pickup.
It really is.
Moving us along now to the job.
YouTube上有一个视频，但她说大约有一个小时长。这太疯狂了。有人在乐高上走了一个小时。作为一个家长，我脑子里想的只有，哦，天哪，完事后是谁得把那些讨厌的乐高积木全捡起来？对。那得捡好大一堆乐高。确实如此。我们现在把话题转到工作这一集。
Fan catch from Erica Jane.
My thought was that maybe this episode is called the job, not because of all the people who
are vying for the corporate job, but because of Jan's boob job.
I saw a few people sort of had this idea and it cracked me up.
I know.
It is a bit of a double entendre.
Double entend.
Yeah.
来自埃里卡·简的粉丝发现。我的想法是，也许这一集之所以叫“工作”，不是因为所有那些在竞争公司职位的人，而是因为简的丰胸手术。我看到有些人也有这种想法，这让我笑喷了。我知道。这有点像一语双关。双关语。是的。
This episode also featured a really great interview with.
Paul Lieberstein. We got a bunch of mail from people saying how much they loved hearing from him.
And lady, we also had people write in and say that they love our tangents, our soapboxes, our deep
dives, because you apologized, because I think you felt a little self-conscious when you were
sharing about the limelight, the club inside of the Gothic cathedral. Yes, I went on for a long time
and then I realized like, oh my gosh, am I talking too much about this? Well, this feeling of being
self-conscious and trying not to apologize for things you don't need to apologize for, really
resonated with people. And I am very happy to see that we are all going to work on this together.
这一集还播出了一个非常棒的采访，采访对象是保罗·利伯斯坦。我们收到了很多人的来信，说他们有多喜欢听他讲话。而且，女士，我们也有人写信说他们喜欢我们的题外话、我们的长篇大论、我们的深度剖析，因为你道了歉，因为我觉得你在分享聚光灯——那个哥特式大教堂里面的俱乐部时，你觉得有点不好意思。是的，我讲了很长时间，然后我意识到，哦，天哪，我是不是说得太多了？好吧，这种不好意思的感觉，以及尽量不去为那些你不需要道歉的事情道歉的感觉，真的引起了大家的共鸣。我很高兴看到我们都在为此共同努力。
Yes, we are. Well, guys, that pretty much wraps it up. But before we go, we did get a question
for our sound engineer, Sam. Sarah Vakari would like to know, where are you from in Wisconsin?
Oh, I am from Watertown, Wisconsin. It's halfway between Madison and Milwaukee. And our mascot was a
Gosling. It was a very intimidating baby goose in a sweater.
Oh. Go baby goose in your little sweater.
Angela's doing some candlesticks as she cheers that cheer for your tiny goose.
Jazz hands. And speaking of local treasures, I wanted to give a shout out to Christy Adventures.
She sent us a walking tour guide of Scranton. It's like a whole map. It's amazing. And I've already
是的，我们是的。好吧，伙计们，差不多就到这里了。但在我们离开之前，我们确实收到了一个关于我们的音响师萨姆的问题。萨拉·瓦卡里想知道，你是威斯康星州哪里人？哦，我来自威斯康星州的沃特敦。它在麦迪逊和密尔沃基之间。我们的吉祥物是一只小鹅。那是一只穿着毛衣、非常吓人的小鹅宝宝。哦。加油，穿着小毛衣的小鹅宝宝。安吉拉在为那声为你的小鹅加油的欢呼声做一些烛台动作。爵士手势。说到当地的宝贝，我想对克里斯蒂·冒险表达谢意。她给我们寄了一份斯克兰顿的步行旅游指南。这就像一张完整的地图。太棒了。我已经
looked at it a few times. You gave me one and I literally love it. Yeah. We will use that when we
go. Well, there you have it, guys. We have revisited the second half of season three. Thank you to Randall Einhorn
for talking with us. And thank you to Jackie Debiton for sending in those audio clips. Yes, and thank you to you
all for sending in your questions and comments. There were a lot. We tried to get to as many as we could.
I know we missed some guys. I know we did. But, you know, we'll just keep chipping away at them.
If you want to send us a question or comments, head over to the Office Ladies Pod Instagram.
We check all our comments there.
And if you go to our website, OfficeLadies.com, you can find little folders that correspond to each episode.
看了好几遍了。你给了我一份，我简直爱不释手。是的。我们去的时候会用上的。好吧，事情就是这样，伙计们。我们已经重温了第三季的后半部分。感谢兰德尔·艾因霍恩与我们交谈。感谢杰基·德比顿给我们发来那些音频剪辑。是的，也谢谢你们所有人发送你们的问题和评论。有很多。我们尽量回答了尽可能多的问题。我知道我们漏掉了一些，伙计们。我知道我们漏了。但是，你知道的，我们会继续一点点攻克它们的。如果你想给我们发送问题或评论，请前往Office Ladies Pod的Instagram。我们在那里查看所有的评论。如果你去我们的网站OfficeLadies.com，你可以找到与每一集相对应的文件夹。
That's where we pull the questions for our regular episodes and for our revisited.
Yes.
And on Office Ladies' Pod, if you could put your question or comment to the episode it pertains to, that way it has a better chance of making it in.
Wait.
wait guys that sounded like something i would say angela am i rubbing off on you you just directed people
to an organizational technique i've never been so excited oh gosh i didn't know that would do it for you
like that i'll throw out some more of my home organization tips okay please all right guys we
will be back next week with a regular episode love you love you guys take care thank you for listening
那就是我们提取常规剧集和重温剧集问题的地方。是的。在Office Ladies' Pod上，如果你能把你的问题或评论发到它所属的那一集下面，这样它入选的机会就会更大。等等。等等，伙计们，听起来这像我会说的话。安吉拉，我是在潜移默化地影响你吗？你刚才引导大家使用了一种我从未听过的组织技巧。我从来没有这么兴奋过。哦，天哪，我不知道这能让你这么激动。那我再多抛出一些我的家庭组织技巧吧。好的，请吧。好吧，伙计们，我们下周会带着常规剧集回来。爱你们。爱你们，伙计们。保重。谢谢你们收听
to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and
Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill
Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
Office Ladies。Office Ladies是Audyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔，音响师是萨姆·基弗。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。Office Ladies由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。